Wer diese Töne hört, der weiß, welche Stunde und welcher Wochentag geschlagen hat. Können Wochentage schlagen? Keine Ahnung, jedenfalls jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat Chaos Radio hier bei Fritz, der Computer-Bimmun und Fritz, Chaos Computer Club und mit Jonny.
Ich, Ni, San, Schi.
Jetzt geht das erst mal wieder los mit den ganzen Mikrofonchecks. Und wer überhaupt im Studio ist heute, von Chaos Computer Club. Weil eins steht fest, Tim ist nicht dabei und das dürfte... Ist das das erste Mal, dass Tim nicht dabei ist?
Tatsache. Aber ich war wahrscheinlich auch gerade im Urlaub.
Frank, erzähl mal, wie alles da ist und dann sagen wir mal, worum es geht heute.
Ja, mit uns ist noch hier Andreas, Felix und Mike und es geht heute um Spezialcomputer, so haben wir die Sendung mal genannt. Wir wollen uns heute unterhalten über so Sachen, wie sie in Video-Recordern eingebaut sind, wie sie in Organisern eingebaut sind, wie sie Raumschiffe steuern. Die ganzen vielen kleinen Computer, die man nicht sieht und die nicht so unbedingt aussehen wie ein PC, aber die trotzdem immer wichtiger für unser Leben werden und immer noch einer der größten Umsatzfaktoren für die Computerindustrie sind.
Schwierig zu sagen, ob das ein Rewix ist oder ein CD hängt.
Moment, klingt es jetzt tatsächlich so, als ob ein CD hängt.
Warte mal, ganz kurz. Das wär doof, ne?
Hängt sehr gut an.
Super.
Stimmt ja selbstgebracht.
Und derweil hören wir noch ein bisschen den Remix von Nummer 8. Garantiere jetzt erstmal nicht dafür, dass es genauso klingt wie das hier, sondern... Und nicht, dass wir irgendwie komplett besoffen wären oder das nicht mitgekriegt hätten. Natürlich haben wir gemerkt, dass die CD hängt. Das war ein Hörer-Test mit CD. Wir wollten sie eigentlich 13 Minuten lang hängen lassen, um zu gucken, was passiert, aber es ist nichts passiert. Deswegen haben wir es dann selber gemacht. Ihr hört Chaos Radio und das fängt so an, wie Chaos Radio anzufangen hat, nämlich mit ein bisschen Chaos. Bevor wir über Spezialcomputer reden, gibt es noch ein paar Spezialhinweise eigentlich. Denn wer in den letzten Tagen oder wie zum Beispiel heute, so wie ich mal, auf www.ccc.de geguckt hat, der hat da grafisch und inhaltlich eine kleine Veränderung festgestellt. Da ist die Rede von einem Raumschiff, der Herz aus Gold, die in diesem Sommer wegen Reparaturen hier landen muss. Und zwar genau gesagt am 6. 7. und 8. August 1999. Und das wird dann für das Chaos-Communication-Camp benutzt. Wie darf ich das verstehen, Frank?
Na, wir haben ja eine außerirdische Kontaktgruppe, die halt ständig Kontakt mit den uns umgebenden Wesenheiten hält. Und da gab es halt eine Anfrage von einem Raumschiff, das hier in der Nähe gestrandet ist. Die haben halt kleine Probleme und brauchen halt ein paar Hacker, die ihnen helfen, ihr Raumschiff wieder zu reparieren. Und durch so ein paar schwierige Dinge, die uns unser Leiter der außerirdischen Kontaktgruppe, Theodor Prinz, gleich erläutern wird, war es halt so, dass sie halt ausgerechnet am 6. 7.
8.
August hier vor Ort sind, in der Nähe von Berlin. Und da werden wir uns dann treffen mit den Jungs und ihre Rakete reparieren und bei der Gelegenheit eine Menge Zelte aufstellen, viel Internet auf der grünen Wiese haben. Und ja, einen Hacker-Fanlager verbringen.
Und wie es der Zufall so will, haben wir genau diesen Mann, der uns jetzt mehr erzählen kann, aus der anderen Sicht sozusagen, nämlich Theodor Prinz von der intergalaktischen Kontaktgruppe des Chaos Computer Clubs, am Telefon. Empfängst du uns?
Ja, wir haben hier gerade mehrere Frequenz-Überlagerungen, aber ich muss mich noch mal kurz terrestrische synchronisieren, Moment! Ja, hier Theodor Prinz.
Ja, wir hören dich gut.
Wir haben irgendwie, die letzten Tage war ein bisschen schwierig, aber wir haben den Kontakt gewinnt, derzeit gerade noch ganz positiv aufrechterhalten. Gibt's da noch Fragen?
Ja, Fragen gibt's zu eurer Landung im August.
Ja.
Kannst du uns ein bisschen mehr drüber erzählen?
Ja, also wir haben mit der Crew jetzt noch permanenten Kontakt und es gestaltet sich technisch ein bisschen schwierig. Die müssen halt irgendwie ihre Systeme irgendwie auf das terrestrische System resynchronisieren und das wird einige Monate noch in Anspruch nehmen. Und wir programmieren gerade die Systeme so um, dass sie hier mit der Erdzeit sich gleichschalten und dann runtergehen direkt in der Nähe von Berlin. Wir haben uns also mit denen über einen Landeplatz verständigen können und das sieht ganz gut aus soweit.
Und was wird der Landeplatz sein?
Bitte?
Was wird der Landeplatz sein? Was? Der Landeplatz.
Ja, das ist so ein großer Acker.
Ach so ein Acker. Und ihr wisst aber genau, dass ihr an diesen drei Tagen dann auf jeden Fall hier sein werdet.
Jaja, das geht alles klar.
Wir müssen ja einiges vorbereiten.
Wir brauchen vor allem viele Leute, die mithelfen für die Reprogrammierung, weil wir brauchen eine enorme Rechenkapazität. Und sobald irgendwie das Raumschiff sozusagen im Orbitkreis und den Kontaktkörper auf die Erde runtergelassen hat, werden wir uns da kurz schließen und dann machen wir da die Verbindung.
Schon ganz für die intergalaktische Kontaktgruppe, das war schon ein extrem interessanter Dialekt, den du hast. Okay, Theodor Prinz war das von der intergalaktischen Kontaktgruppe des Chaos Computer Clubs. Mehr zu dieser Landung, mehr zum Chaos Communication Camp am 6. 7. und 8. August. In diesem Jahr findet ihr unter www.ccc.de. Man sollte vielleicht auch, wo wir noch relativ am Beginn dieser Stunden bis 10 Uhr noch sind, sollte man sagen, dass unter www.fritz.de der Link zum Stream, zum Audiostream in Rea Audio gefunden werden. Also alle im Internet, die im Chat sitzen, z.B. unter www.fritz.de slash v-chat oder in anderen Chats im IC oder auch im Tenet-Chat. Läuft der?
Ja, ne?
Der ist mit SSH gesichert, aber er läuft, ja.
Also alle, die jetzt im Internet unterwegs sind und vielleicht Leute treffen, die nicht in Brandenburg in unserem Gebiet von Fritz wohnen, den kann man sagen, dass unter www.fritz.de der Rea Audio Stream abgelegt ist und ja, chatten kann mit uns. Ihr könnt uns natürlich auch immer schicken und nachher darf man auch anrufen. So viel dazu und gleich legen wir los. So, jetzt werden wir ein bisschen aus der Hüfte kommen hier langsam. Frank, Andreas, Felix und Mike sind hier vom Chaos Computer Club und wir reden über Spezialcomputer und zwar mit Spezialcomputer gibt es ganz viel verschiedene. Kann jemand vielleicht so einen groben Abriss der nächsten zweieinhalb Stunden, zwei Stunden, vierzig Minuten geben über welche Spezialcomputer? Über mein Lieblingszimmer natürlich, elektronische Spielzeuge, Gadgets, also PDAs, Kleinstcomputer, Handhelds, keine Ahnung, was da alles noch mit reinfällt. Aber auch über Spezialcomputer, die man gar nicht so richtig sieht, oder?
Na ja, wenn wir ehrlich sind, Johnny, dann haben wir dieses Thema natürlich nur gewählt, damit du auch mal irgendwie was fachliches beitragen kannst.
Ich hab nicht gesagt, dass ich da was fachliches beitragen kann.
Mal sehen, bist du irgendwie einer der gadget-erfahrensten Leute, die ich so kenne?
Das stimmt.
Immer bekloppt genug Geräte zu kaufen, wenn du jetzt schon weißt, dass sie völlig outdated sind und natürlich nicht upgradable und...
Kannst du denn ihren Funktionsumfang voll ausschöpfen, wenigstens?
Na, in drei Monaten schafft man das dann und dann merkt man, dass er nicht reicht, der Funktionsumfang. Und da gibt es aber auch schon ein neues Gerät.
Ich meine, es gibt halt irgendwie im Marketing dort diesen schönen Begriff der Early Adopters Strafgebühr. Das ist halt der Preisaufschlag, der auf die ersten Geräte immer gemacht wird. Für Verrückte wie uns, die sich diese Dinge dann trotzdem kaufen.
Wobei ich auch dazu sagen muss, dass ich die Erfahrung, die ich mit diesen Geräten habe, natürlich auch viel von Testgeräten habe. Also, dass man dann sagen konnte, ich würde das Gerät gerne drei Wochen mal testen. Das geht ja als Journalist. Dann muss man es halt manchmal mit Schmerz zurückschicken. Und manchmal ist man dann total froh, dass man das Testgerät hat und nicht etwa 1000 Mark dafür ausgegeben hat.
Ja, das ist natürlich ein echter Vorteil.
Kann man den Test dann verlängern, eigentlich?
Ich glaube, in bestimmten Fällen kannst du das machen.
Ja, aber wir wollen ja auch noch über andere Spezialcomputer reden, nämlich über die, die man nicht sieht, die in Geräten des Alltags drin sind und die da still ihre Dienste verrichten. Vor allen Dingen dadurch auffallen, dass sie in der Regel nicht abstürzen, wie man das von Computern, die auf dem Schreibtisch stehen, gewohnt ist.
Werden wir sowas wie diesen komischen Hype ansprechen, der ja durch viele bunte, bunte Zeitschriften geht und gegangen ist und immer noch geht es, also Geschichten wie der Kühlschrank kommuniziert mit meinen Schuhen, die mit dem Auto kommunizieren, die beim Bäcker die Milch bestellen und solche Geschichten?
Naja, also es wird gar nicht so nur um die Geräte geben, die es heute gibt, sondern für das Verständnis der Geräteladenschaft, die es so auf dem Markt gibt und auch nicht nur auf dem Markt, sondern da, wo man sie halt nicht kennt, ist es auch wichtig zu verstehen, wie es denn gekommen ist zu den Rechnern von heute. Und wir haben hier auch eine ganz lustige Geschichte über das erste Embedded-Gerät. Da wird Frank nachher was zu erzählen. Also es geht gar nicht so darum, nur jetzt Kühlschränke auseinanderzunehmen und wir werden auch einen weiten Bogen darum machen, zu erläutern, ob Kühlschränke das Jahr 2000 Problem haben. Also solche Anrufe bitten wir doch dann gleich zu lassen. Da haben wir eine Extrasendung für geplant.
Gibt es denn schon Kühlschränke für das Jahr 2000 Problem, oder für Kühlschränke die Extrasendung? Gibt es denn schon Kühlschränke, wann machen wir die Sendung im Dezember, oder?
Der Termin steht noch nicht ganz fest, aber wir werden auf jeden Fall eine Sendung machen, weil da kommen wir dann wohl doch nicht drum rum, ob wir was eigentlich lange geplant haben, drum rumzukommen. Und insofern denke ich mal, wird die in einem der nächsten zwei oder drei Monate stattfinden.
Also wir können total beruhigt sein. Wir werden euch zu diesem Problem in den nächsten zwei, drei Monaten definitiv helfen. Wir können jetzt einfach alles so lassen, wie es ist.
Wir haben schon Angebote von mehreren namhaften Notstromgeneratoren für diese Sendung.
Schön wäre, wenn uns dann irgendetwas ausfällt. Es gibt ja auch das Jahr 99 Probleme, weil wir auch nicht wissen, das ist wichtig, ja.
Deswegen haben wir Laptopcomputer hier.
Das ist die Notversorgung für ein paar Stunden zumindest eingebaut.
Naja, für eineinhalb Malstens, oder?
Das hängt vom Modell ab und von der Batterie.
Heute im ChaosRadio Spezialcomputer, Winston Atikendler, nach dem Fritz Kurb, wo er es richtig loslegen wird, wird er über das erste Thema sein, über das Reden.
Wir werden bei der Gestellung der Embedded-Systeme anfangen, sozusagen von zwar an.
Vielleicht mal kurz, was Embedded-Systeme sind?
Ja, Embedded-Systeme, also Embedded steht englisch für eingebettet. Das ist eigentlich am Anfang eher ein Wunsch gewesen als tatsächliche Beobachtung. Gemeint sind Professoren, die in anderen Geräten, die draußen rein mechanisch aussehen, oder vielleicht auch ein Elektrosteuer, wie zum Beispiel ein Herd, der Temperatur hat, oder dem ich sagen kann, es ist ein Braten, der soll irgendwie durch sein, ist so und so groß, das gibt es ja heutzutage, und der weiß dann eben, wie lange er braten soll. Da ist dann gewöhnlich eben ein kleiner Prozessor drin und ein kleines Programmchen läuft darauf ab. Und diese Prozessoren, die sind natürlich bei weitem nicht so teuer und so groß und so mächtig wie Prozessoren, die man heute so in seinem Laptop mit sich herumschleppt. Und deswegen ist das Hauptunterscheidungsmerkmal zwischen normalen und Embedded-Prozessoren gewöhnlich auch der Preis. Gewöhnlich ist das sogar so, dass Embedded-Prozessoren von heute die Desktop-Prozessoren von ein paar Jahren waren. Besonders beliebt sind momentan Lips-Prozessoren, die eben früher in Workstations von Silicon Graphics zum Beispiel drin waren.
Mit anderen Worten, ich könnte eigentlich, wenn ich jetzt einen sehr modernen Herd habe, dann könnte ich den auseinander nehmen und mir daraus ein sehr veraltetes Laptop bauen.
Ja, Laptops haben diese Teile gewöhnlich nicht gehabt, aber könnte man natürlich bauen, nur gibt es da natürlich dann keine Mainboards für, dann müsste es also echt innovativ werden.
Aber ich hätte einen Laptop, der...
Das wäre der coolste Laptop in Deutschland.
Das ist schon okay.
Das alles, also gleich mehr kann auch jemand sagen, von wem die Musik kommt heute?
Ich komme mal wieder von Don Stone, einem unserer Lieblings-Dj's.
Von Don Stone und ich sag jetzt nochmal ganz kurz an, wo ihr uns virtuell finden könnt im Netz unter www.fritz.de. Dort findet ihr zwei Links, also da findet ihr mehr Links, aber in Sachen Chaosradio findet ihr einmal den Real Audio Stream, also live übers Internet diese Sendung hören und auch den Link zum V-Chat, den findet man aber auch unter www.fritz.de im IRC gibt es garantiert auch Kanäle, die dann wahrscheinlich Chaosradio heißen, in denen man sich unterhalten kann. Ist da noch etwas wichtiges zu sagen? Nö, wir. Gleich gibt es erst mal kurz Info und dann geht es los. Weiter geht es dann los, dann ist es ja schon lange.
Wenn Fritz im Raum an der Munde, dann 100, 1.
22.31 Uhr.
Notlage, die Fluchtwille aus dem Kosovo hält an. Nach Schätzungen der Organisation für Sicherheit und Zusammenarbeit in Europa haben allein in Albanien fast 100.000 Menschen Schutz gesucht. Auch aus der Provinzhauptstadt Pristina werden Kosovo-Albaner vertrieben. Kriegsspirale. Die NATO will ihre Luftangriffe gegen Jugoslawien ausweiten. Mögliche Ziele seien nun auch Regierungsgebäude in der Hauptstadt Belgrad, hieß es in Brüssel. Die Einsätze sollen auch über Ostern fortgesetzt werden. Diplomatie. Russland will sich weiter um eine friedliche Lösung im Kosovo-Krieg bemühen. Das erklärte Ministerpräsident Primakov. Zudem will Russland Präsenz im Mittelmeer zeigen und Kriegsschiffe entsenden. Aussage. Die EU-Kommission hat keine Einwände mehr gegen die deutsche Ökosteuer. Die Kommission werde demnächst ihre Zustimmung erzahlen, sagt ein EU-Sprecher in Brüssel. Die Ökosteuer tritt morgen in Kraft.
Sport.
Fußball. Die deutsche Nationalmannschaft siegte in ihrem EM-Qualifikationsspiel gegen Finnland mit 2 zu 0. Im Nürnberger Frankenstadion schossen Jeremies und Neuville die Tore für den amtierenden Europameister. Heute Nacht kriegen bewirkt 6 bis 0 Grad am Tage nach Nebelauflösungen meist sonnig Temperaturen 14 bis 18 Grad. Keine aktuellen Meldungen.
Das war Gerald Kratzer-Heinreich mit dem Fritz Kortzenfo.
Fritz präsentiert. Ein Ballsportspiel. Der Alba Klasse. Alba Berlin gegen TTL Bamberg. Ostermontag, 5. April um 15 Uhr in der Max-Schmähling-Halle. Karten gibt's fast überall. Und beim Fritz Mützen Telefon. 0331 für Potsdam, 70 97 120. Alba Berlin gegen TTL Bamberg. Das dritte Spiel. April um 15 Uhr in der Max-Schmähling-Halle. Karten gibt's fast überall.
Und wie immer gilt, wenn Alba, dann Fritz. Thema heute hier im Computer-Blummen bei Fritz. Jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat übrigens mit dem Chaos Computer Club. Und mit Jonny. Spezialcomputer von Embedded Systems haben wir gerade gehört. Eingebettete Systeme, eingebettete Computer. Und geschichtlich werden wir gleich hören, wie groß der erste eingebettete Computer war und wofür er genutzt wurde. Wer ist denn der Experte für die Embedded Systems bei euch?
Na, wir haben da keinen wirklichen Experten, sondern wir haben eigentlich alle mehr oder minder damit zu tun mit solchen Systemen.
Wir sind ein Komitee.
Genau, wir sind ein Komitee. Ja, ich hab gerade nochmal nachgeguckt, Onggi. Die erste Referenz auf ein Embedded-System, also ein System, das kein dedizierter Personalcomputer, sondern oder ein Großrechner oder was auch immer, sondern ein System war, das irgendwie nicht zweiteinhalb als eine Maschine steuern, außerhalb des militärischen Bereiches. Das war eine Digital PDP-8. Die PDP-8 war für sich ein relativ revolutionärer Computer, der wurde 1965 eingeführt. Und eines der wesentlichen Vorteilsargumente für die PDP-8 war, dass digital damals alle Fraktionen dieser Maschine, also alle Manuals, wie man es programmiert, wie die Hardware aufgebaut ist und so weiter und so fort, vollständig frei den Leuten zur Verfügung gestellt. Das heißt, man hat einfach angerufen oder einen Brief hingeschrieben und gesagt, ich hätte gerne einmal die Manuals. Und dann bekam man so 20 Kilo Papier ins Haus geschippt und konnte dann die Maschine programmieren. Die war damals ziemlich billig. Also als sie eingeführt wurde, kostete sie 18.000 Dollar. Und es fiel dann doch relativ bald so auf ungefähr 10.000 Dollar. Und es war damals ein revolutionieriger Preis für so eine Maschine. Und wie gesagt, das erste System, das ich gefunden habe, wo sie tatsächlich eine PDP-8 als Controller für irgendwie eine Maschine benutzt haben, war ein Kartoffel-Armter. Also da haben sie halt echt so eine, ich habe hier gerade das Foto von mir, auch so eine Kartoffel-Armter-Maschine, da ist dann oben so eine große graue Kiste drauf, wo dann halt irgendwie die PDP-8 drinsteckt.
So groß im Sinne von Kühlschrank.
Also drinsteckt ist vielleicht auch zu viel gesagt.
Also die sitzt da halt so drauf, genau. Weil sie selber sich tatsächlich auf so einen Kühlschrank großen klotz, der halt tatsächlich dann diesen Computer beherbergt. Ich meine, die Maschine war irgendwie damals doch irgendwie relativ revolutionär. Sie konnte doch immerhin 35.000 Additionen pro Sekunde. Das war schon echt viel.
Ja, also die PDP8 selber war sehr erfolgreich und deswegen gab es da auch weitere Modelle von. Aber der Prozessor selbst war irgendwie sehr merkwürdig. Der war ein 12-Bit-Prozessor und hatte genau drei Register. Und die ganzen Instruktionen mit zwei Operanten haben dann immer aus zweien gelesen, nämlich also AC und MQ und haben immer nach AC zurückgeschrieben. Also man war doch sehr liezimilitiert, was man da überhaupt machen konnte. War noch akkumulatorbasiert. Das ist eine Sache, die ist dann ziemlich schnell weggegangen. Es gibt eigentlich heute nur noch eine Art von CPU, die noch Akkumulatoren benutzt. Und das ist die Floating-Point-Einheit bei Intel. Ansonsten ist das ausgestorben. Und damals dieser Prozessor war also ziemlich brand-damaged, weil der RAM war limitiert auf 4 Kilo-Byte. Das war selbst damals ziemlich wenig. Und Memory-Referenzen, also Speicher-Zugriffe, konnte man nur relativ zum Anfang des Speichers machen und relativ zum Programm-Counter. Also da, wo der Code gerade ausgeführt wurde und konnte dann auch nicht volle 4K adressieren von da aus, sondern nur 7-Bit-Referenzen. Das heißt, man musste den Code, der die Daten bearbeitet, immer neben die Daten tun. Das heißt, man musste, wenn man sehr große Arrays bearbeiten wollte, wie irgendwelche numerischen Bearbeitungen, wie viele Rechner damals eben benutzt wurden, musste man den Code verteilen über seinen Adressraum. Das war also überhaupt nicht sinnvoll. Aber die Kiste war eben sehr erfolgreich, weil sie vor allem auch ziemlich günstig war. Es gab damals als Alternative eigentlich nur irgendwelche Research-Systeme und IBM-Großrechner und die waren halt richtig teuer, wie sie heute eigentlich noch ziemlich teuer sind.
Warum galt dieses System nun als Geburts sozusagen der Embedded Systems?
Da galt es ja gar nicht, aber es ist halt zum ersten Mal als Embedded System benutzt worden. Das ist auch mehr ein Joke der Geschichte.
In welchen Witzgeschichtbüchern ist das sowas da drin? Das steht gerade in das Foto her.
Wir haben hier zwei Bücher, die können wir gleich mal plagen bei der Gelegenheit.
Genau, ich habe hier einmal von Tsurutsi, History of Modern Computing. Das ist schon etwas, den man gut so in einer knappen Woche durchbekommt, wo halt einfach so die Uraanfänge der Rechner bis zu den heutigen Architekturen beschrieben sind. Interessant sind dann halt so Bemerkungen, wie nachdem dann der PC im Wesentlichen erfunden war, hat sich daran nichts mehr Wesentliches geändert.
Ja, ich meine, es ist doch nicht ganz falsch. Das andere Buch ist das Buch zum Thema Rechnerarchitektur. Man kann sich jetzt den Titel merken. Das ist Computer Architecture Quantitative Approaches. Das gibt es auch als deutsche Übersetzung. Das empfehle ich aber nicht.
Das heißt dann aber auch nicht viel anders.
Das heißt auch nicht viel anders. Ja, die zweite Auflage gibt es inzwischen. Also vielleicht gibt es auch eine dritte, da weiß ich aber noch nichts von. Von Hennessey und Patterson. Das heißt, wer das haben will, geht zu Lemans und sagt Hennessey und Patterson. Die haben nämlich genau dieses Buch und noch eine BWL-Version davon geschrieben. Die ist halt ein bisschen leichter zu verstehen für Leute, die halt die Zahlen irgendwie von links nach rechts erlernen. Aber der Inhalt ist im Grunde der gleiche. Und das ist das Rechnerarchitekturbuch. Also das Architekturbuch, das ist auch ziemlich dick und kostet auch eine Menge Geld. Aber wer sich für das Thema interessiert, das ist das Buch.
Ja, jetzt sollten wir vielleicht mal die Embedded-Controller-Familien ansprechen. Also das geht ja mit der PDP8 nicht so weiter, die auf den Traktor draufzuschnallen. Das war ein bisschen unpraktisch.
Ist auch eher ein Pressegag von digital.
Wahrscheinlich. Na ja, es gibt eigentlich, wenn ich das richtig sehe, drei Familien von Prozessoren, die auch heute noch gerne in Geräten verwendet werden. Also wir reden jetzt darüber Mikrowellen, Waschmaschinen, Taschenrechner.
Digitale Kamera.
Föhnens, alles Mögliche wird ja heutzutage von Rechnern gesteuert. Und die Prozessoren, die da drin sind, sind also der 6502 fällt mir spontan ein als der verbreitete. Dann die 8051-Architektur und dann die ganzen Pics. Ich denke, die machen dann so 90 Prozent insgesamt aller Controller aus, also aller kleinen Controller.
Ja, das hat sich heute ein bisschen verschoben. Das war vor ein paar Jahren noch so. Inzwischen ist es so, dass auch im Dead-It-Markt mit 32-Bit-Prozessoren gearbeitet wird. Und zwar gar nicht so, wenn man es braucht, sondern weil halt die Compiler da inzwischen einfach ausgereifter sind. Und die Hersteller haben keine Lust für jede Toolchain, für jede Prozessor-Architektur in eigenen Compiler zu warten. Und deswegen werden inzwischen heute gerne alte 32-Bit-CPUs benutzt. Besonders beliebt ist der MIPS. MIPS ist wirklich fast überall drin inzwischen. Und das liegt daran, dass die CPUs schon immer 32-Bit waren, auch wo sie früher intern so völlig abgespeckt implementiert waren. Und die Version, wenn ihm heute verkauft, die kriegt beim Tür zwei Dollar. Und ich hab mich ja sehr gefreut, dass in meiner Digitalkamera ein Spark drin ist. Das ist eigentlich aus Sunwork Stations der Prozessor, wo ich gar nicht wusste, dass der im embedded überhaupt verkauft würde. Ja, was noch ganz beliebt ist, Power-PCs hab ich gehört, weiß ich aber nicht, wo die konkret eingesetzt werden. Jedenfalls Motorola überlebt, weil da irgendwelche embedded Systeme mit verkauft werden.
Vor allen Dingen, also die verkaufen vor allen Dingen viel von den 68K-Systemen. Also zum Beispiel, da kommen wir später noch drauf, irgendwie der Palm Pilot, da steckt ja auch ein 68K drin. Mittlerweile ist ja allein der Prozessor am Palm Pilot irgendwie mehrfach so schnell wie einer der damals beliebten Homecomputer der Amiga 500.
Na Motorola hat schon einen sehr genialen Embedded Prozessor auf PowerPC-Basis im Angebot. Also das Problem bei Embedded Prozessoren überhaupt bei Prozessoren ist, dass der halt nur Prozessor ist, der kann nicht irgendwie Speicher verwalten und so. Das machen Prozessoren gewöhnlich nicht. Und wenn man jetzt einen Rechner baut, dann ist da ein Mainboard dabei, da ist dann ein RAM-Controller, ein Interrupt-Controller. Gut, Interrupts braucht man jetzt gewöhnlich nicht bei irgendwelchen Embedded-Systemen. Na ja gut.
Aber hallo, natürlich braucht man die.
Kommt drauf an, es gibt doch viele, die auf Prolin basieren. Aber ist ja auch egal. Letztendlich, da sind viele Support-Chips drauf, die man eigentlich beim Embedded-System gerne gleich in einer Packung haben möchte. Und das Endziel sind sogenannte Ballpoint-Chips, die kommen als ein großer Chip mit ungefähr 400, 500 Pins raus. Und da ist eigentlich alles drauf, was man haben möchte, inklusive ein bisschen RAM und ein bisschen ROM am besten, damit da die Software schon drauf ist. Und bei den Herstellern geht man, und dann kann man dann auf die Webseiten gehen und zusammenklicken, was man denn jetzt gerne als Features drauf haben möchte, ob der jetzt schnell addieren können soll oder lieber multiplizieren, ob der überhaupt Floating Point braucht. Sowas gibt es halt als Embedded-Varianten. Und bei Motorola gibt es sogar einen Chip, der eben auch Ethernet dann onboard hat. Dann schließt man also einfach sein Netzwerk an und kann dann eben Ethernet fahren damit, dass es relativ positioniert.
Ich hab einen Vorschlag, dann fangen wir mit der 65012 an.
65002, naja, also wir haben ja... Ich glaube nicht. Wir haben zwar immer ziemlich interessante Phänomene zu tun.
Den kleineren Schatze kommen wir nie durch, ne? Ahja, ist doch auch ein ernstes Thema.
Als alter Gadget hier. Wir haben immer interessante Phänomene zu tun. Und zwar ist es immer so, dass die Embedded-Systeme sind immer so ein oder zwei Technologiegenerationen hinter denen. Dem her, was so normal in den Schreibtischcomputern drin steckt. Und einer der wichtigsten Embedded-CPUs heutzutage ist eine CPU, die vielen von uns lange in Heimcomputern bekannt war. Unter anderem auch im berühmten C64. Das ist die 6502-CPU.
Und da sagt uns Felix jetzt was dazu.
Also die 6500X-Serie, da gehörten auch mehrere Prozessoren zu, ist schon 1975 von Motorola gestartet worden. Also nicht direkt von Motorola, sondern von einigen Designern, die da eben weggelaufen sind und die später von Commodore gekauft wurden. Und dieser Prozessor, der war am Anfang. Also man kann an den Prozessoren von früher sehr gut so Sachen feststellen, weil man beobachten kann, welche Dinge probiert wurden und dann nie wieder auftauchten, weil sie sich halt nicht als sinnvoll erwiesen haben. Und bei frühen Prozessoren sieht man, also ganz am Anfang war es so, dass Prozessoren eben akkumulatorbasiert sind. Die akkumulatoren basierte Systeme waren Akkumulator, so ein archerascher Ausdruck. Und heißt, dass es genau ein Register gibt, womit man eben Speichervariablen zusammenzielen kann. Akkumulieren heißt zusammenzählen und dann kann man die eben irgendwo hinschreiben wieder. Und Taschenrechner basiert gewöhnlich darauf. Und dann hat man auch versucht größere Rechner damit zu bauen. Und in 65.0x war das noch so, dass die Register so teilweise festgelegt waren. Man konnte nicht mit jedem Register alles machen, wie das heute in den RISC-CPUs so ist, sondern das war eben aufgeteilt. Und jetzt gibt es noch eine Unterscheidung bei Prozessoren, die auch heute noch wichtig ist, wenn man in Netzwerken arbeitet, nämlich in welcher Reihenfolge die Bytes abgespeichert werden. Also wenn man jetzt eine Variable hat, die mehr als einen Byte beinhaltet, wie zum Beispiel eine größere Zahl, das sind gewöhnlich 32 Bitwerte, das sind 4 Bytes, dann kann man eben das kleinste, das niederwertigste Byte zuerst ablegen oder das höherwertigste Byte. Und die erste Variante nennt man Little Engine, die wird zum Beispiel von Intel gefahren oder auch von den 6502 Systemen. Und die Begründung war damals, dass man dann die Adressgenerierung schon mal anfangen kann, während man das zweite Byte noch lädt aus dem Speicher, weil das erste halt zuerst kommt. Ob den Speicher wurde eben noch seriell zugegriffen, heute ist das ganz anders bei den Prozessoren, da werden immer Blocks oder Pages gelesen aus dem Speicher. Und früher war das eben so, dass die CPUs noch viel langsamer waren, als der Speicher zugegriffen. Und deswegen haben die Prozessorhersteller auf den Speicher zugegriffen optimiert. Und der 6802, ähm, quatscht der 6502, und die ganze Produktlinie hat eben noch diese Optimierung gehabt, auf den Speicher zugegriffen und noch kein Cache wie heutige Systeme. Und als die Prozessoren schneller wurden, sind solche Features eben obsolet geworden.
Ja, der 6502 war im C64 drin, war im Apple II drin, soweit ich weiß. Und es gab dann noch weitere wichtige Systeme, die wir gerade entfallen sind.
Frank greift zum Buch.
Also wir haben uns überlegt, wenn wir heute zeigen wollen, dass ein Thema ganz obskur und orkan ist, dass wir dann zum Buch greifen und ein bisschen blättern.
Ist das nicht online oder was?
Hey, das ist alles verstaubtes Wissen von vor 20 Jahren.
Genau, das macht es ja so schön, das macht es ja so.
Ja, was interessant ist, dass man da wirklich richtig Sachen daraus lernen kann. Also vor allen Dingen, wie sich halt so Wissen unter den Ingenieuren entwickelt und vor allen Dingen, wie wichtig die Leute tatsächlich in diesem Business sind. Also viel von dem Wissen wird halt immer dadurch transferiert, dass halt jemand irgendeine Firma verlässt, eine eigene Firma gründet oder zu einer anderen Firma geht. Also da werden wir später noch mehrere Male drauf kommen, dass halt einfach so Technologietransfer im Wesentlichen an Personen hängt. Das war irgendwie, was ich so in der Vorbereitung dieser Sendung auch irgendwie gelernt habe. Finde ich interessant.
Also was man bei der 65.0 XR ja auch noch wunderbar sehen kann, wie die meisten früheren CPUs gab es da viele undokumentierte Befehle. Und ursprünglich war das gar nicht undokumentiert, sondern die waren einfach gar nicht vorgesehen vom Chip-Designer. Und was dann passiert, war einfach nicht definiert. Und manchmal hat die CPU dann eben versucht, das zu interpretieren. Und dann kam dann eben irgendwas raus, was vielleicht nützlich sein könnte. Später ist es dann so, also es kann auch vorkommen, dass der Rechner einfach abstürzt an der Stelle. Das war damals eben, dann ist er eben abgestürzt. Und sowas gab es vor kurzem auch beim Pensionprozessor, das eine bestimmte Bitfolge dazu geführt hat, dass er abstürzt. Und heute heulen die Leute dann alle rum, weil es nämlich heißt, dass man ein Multi-User-System oder ein Server abstürzen lassen kann, wenn man eine bestimmte Bitfolge ausführt. Das ist heute echt verboten aus Sicherheitsgründen, aber früher war das gang und gäbe. Und das hat so niemand von den Usern eigentlich mitgekriegt, in diesem Übergang, dass heute von Prozessoren erwartet wird, dass sie alle Bitfolgen abfangen und dann reagieren, indem sie einen bestimmten Interrupt, also dem System mitteilen, dass da gerade versucht wurde, Code auszuführen, der nicht erlaubt ist.
Und wohl Intel hatte doch da vorne ein Ja oder so, hatten sie doch noch ab kurz die CPU gleich noch zum Crashing gebracht, ne?
Ja, ja, eben. Da gab es eben diesen Fuff-Bug. Also lustigerweise war das auch nicht nur so, dass die tatsächlich ungeplant waren, die undokumentierten Instruktionen, sondern es gab da auch Prozessoren, da hat man am Rand so weniger wichtige Instruktionen hingetan. Und wenn bei der Chip-Produktion es dann Fehler gab, dann war das halt meistens am Rand von dem Dye. Und es sorgte dann dafür, dass diese Instruktionen dann eben nicht zuverlässig funktioniert haben, dann hat man die eben nicht dokumentiert. Und die funktionierte dann aber bei den meisten und später hat man den Fertigungsprozess verbessert, das heißt bei allen. Und so führt es dem dazu, dass Instruktionen nicht dokumentiert wurden. Und andere sind auch nicht dokumentiert, weil sie nur für die Bucking benutzt sind, wie dass man alle internen Prozessorregister laden kann, das gab es bei Intel jahrelang. Das ist nicht unbedingt so, dass die Prozessorresteller uns damit ärgern wollen, wie das bei Microsoft und Windows ist, wenn etwas nicht dokumentiert ist, sondern das ist tatsächlich, früher hat das noch richtige Heckergründe gehabt.
Beim 68.000 gab es eine Instruktion, die nannte sich HCF Halt and Catch Fire. Und was sie machte, ist einfach sämtliche Busleitung durchtoggeln, um zu gucken, ob das Businterfers funktioniert.
Ah, hier sind noch ein paar Anwendungen, wo das Teil benutzt wurde. Also erstmal Apple II hat mir schon gesagt, dann steht hier noch in dem Nintendo Entertainment System NES und ein Nachfolger von M6502, nämlich der M6508 116, ist der 16-Bit-Nachfolger, der ist dann im Super Nes benutzt worden. Also auch noch, ich mein gut, ist inzwischen natürlich veraltet, aber gar nicht so weit zurück.
War im Game Boy nicht auch ein M6502? Naja, auf jeden Fall ist dann beim M6502 auch diese Geschichte losgegangen, dass der Prozessor im Prinzip gleich geblieben ist und dass man aber angefangen hat, den aufzubohren, also alles auf 16-Bit oder noch jede Menge Interfaces dazu, Hochtakten bis auf 33 MHz oder weiter, eben für den Einsatz in Embedded-Systemen. Man hat halt damit angefangen, dass man wenige Sachen machen musste, so Temperatur messen und dann Ventil auf und zu drehen, solche Geschichten. Dann wurde es irgendwann komplizierter und dann brauchte man mehr Platz und dann reichten die CPUs nicht aus, aber man hat das ja alles in Assembler programmiert. Das heißt, man konnte das CPU-Design nicht einfach wechseln. Und dadurch wurde halt ein Markt geschaffen für Derivate, die nicht nur mehr Funktionen auf dem Chip drauf haben, wie Businterfaces und so weiter und so fort, sondern die auch schneller sind auf weiteren RAMs arbeiten und so weiter und so fort, mehr Register haben. Alles das hat es gegeben.
Drei haben wir noch, die wir unbedingt nennen sollten.
Ja, die nächste wichtige Prozessorfamilie, die man auch oft in Kühlschränken, Rollschuhen und ähnlichen Dingen antrifft. Das auch, ja. Ist der 8051, den hat Intel damals entwickelt und das ist eine Ausnahme, weil er eigentlich von vornherein als Mikrocontroller gedacht war. Und das ging mit dem 8048 los. Und dann haben sie den ein bisschen aufgebohrt und das war dann der 8051, der immerhin 8 Register hatte und einen Akkumulator. Und ja, diese 8051-Familie, die ist auch sehr, sehr verbreitet und genauso wie bei dem 6502 gibt es jetzt die verschiedensten aufgebohrten Varianten. Unter anderem einen Siemens-Prozessor, der dann 16 und 32 Bit Integer Arithmetik und ein bisschen Floating Point drin hat. Und naja, der 8051 eigentlich der klassische Waschmaschinen-Controller.
Stell mir mal vor, wir Leute jetzt zuhause ihre Palm-Pilots öffnen und den Prozessor aufbohren.
Tut es nicht. Und wenn es tut, wir übernehmen keine Haftung. Wir haben es euch nicht gesagt.
Also wenn ihr es aufschraubt, passt auf, die Drähte, die den Pizobuzzer auf der Rückwand mit der Hauptplatine verbinden, die sind recht dünn und die gehen schnell ab, wenn man die Rückwandplatine abmacht und danach gucken wollt.
Die kriegt man aber auch wieder ran.
Vorsichtig, vorsichtig.
Vorsichtig, genau. Und immer dran denken, wenn man die Batterien eine Minute rausnimmt, dann ist nichts mehr drin.
Schönen Backup zu. Wir waren noch beim 8051, oder? Ja, auf der Registerung kann man...
Der ist eigentlich ein Intel-Prozessor. Wollen wir über den wirklich reden machen? Ja doch, wir müssen...
Nein, ich denke, wir müssen schon sagen, wieso wir über Intel-Prozessoren eigentlich nicht reden wollen. Los, Felix, sag's ihnen.
Über Intel-Prozessoren? Na ja, das versteht man eigentlich erst, wenn man sich dieses toll rechte Architekturbuch durchgelesen hat und versteht, was alles für wunderbare Innovationen auf dem Bereich der Prozessorbautechnik gibt und warum Prozessoren heute so aussehen, wie sie aussehen. Und eine Sache, die man da lernen kann zum Beispiel, ist, wie viele Register in einem Prozessor drin sein sollten, damit Programme optimal schnell ablaufen. Und warum sind überhaupt so viele Prozessoren heutzutage mit 32 Registern ausgestattet? Das ist zum Beispiel eine Sache, die hat sich... So was wird mit Statistiken geklärt. Also was man tut, ist, dass man sich einigt auf eine bestimmte Art von Programmen. Das heißt, man definiert eine Menge von Programmen, von denen man behauptet, dass das eine typische Arbeitslast auf einem Prozessor sind. Und da gehören zum Beispiel ein Compiler dazu oder ein Mathe-Programm, was große Gleichungssysteme löst. Und an der Stelle, was man tut, ist, dass man den Prozessor simuliert auf einem bestehenden Rechner. Und dann nimmt man einfach verschiedene Designs mit verschiedenen vielen Registern. Und das ist ja nicht umsonst, mehr Register in einen Prozessor einzubauen, sondern dadurch wird der Platz auf dem Prozessor enger und der Prozessor kostet mehr. Und man muss also abwägen, ist einem das das Geld wert, die Geschwindigkeitssteigerung. Und es stellt sich also raus, dass 32 Register optimal sind. Und bei früheren Rechnern war das so. Ein Register ist im Grunde nur zwei Transistoren auf dem Prozessor, die allerdings an viele Stellen angebunden sein müssen mit Leitungen, die auf dem Prozessor echt verteilt sind. Das heißt, das ist schon teuer, da jetzt irgendwie 5000 Register aufzutun. Trotzdem gab es auch Prozessoren, die das getan haben. Und Intel war einer von den Prozessorherstellern, die auch nach Jahrzehnten des besseren Wissens die Prozessoren immer noch nur mit irgendwie acht Register bauen. Und so ist es auch bei dem 8051 und auch bei dem neueste Pentium hat irgendwie immer noch nur, wie viel sind das? Acht, neun. Und der floating point ist noch viel katastrophaler bei Intel. Das ist nämlich gar nicht Register, sondern es ist eine Stack-ähnliche Architektur. Das sorgt dafür, dass der Compiler überhaupt nicht anständig optimieren kann, wie Gleichungen jetzt ausgeführt werden. Und wenn man sich das einfach nur von Intel-Seite aus anguckt, sieht das alles gar nicht so schlimm aus. Aber andere Prozessoren können heutzutage Sachen machen, wie dass sie Instruktionen verteilen auf mehrere Ausführungseinheiten. Das heißt, wenn man feststellt, dass die Gleichungssysteme, die man löst, gewöhnlich bestehen aus viele Additionen und Multiplikationen. So was Kalarprodukt ist eine häufige Sache. Dann macht man es eben so, dass man zwei Adira und zwei Multiplizierer einbaut in so einen Prozessor. Und der Prozessor kann dann halt beide Multiplizierer gleichzeitig beschäftigen und die Ergebnisse dann an die beiden Adira geben. Und sowas geht eben nur, wenn man tatsächlich mehrere Register hat. Stack funktioniert immer so, dass man nur die obersten beiden Elemente benutzen kann. Und das heißt, solche Innovationen sind überhaupt nicht möglich mit diesem Registermodell. Und Intel hat da üble Tricks anwenden müssen, die den Prozessor einfach echt teuer machen in der Herstellung und in der Forschung, die dazu nötig ist, dass die Pensions überhaupt so performen, wie sie heute performen. Und der Kunde zahlt im Grunde dafür, deswegen sind wir der Meinung, Intel ist scheiße.
Was heißt denn das in der Praxis nachher? Also ist denn ein Intel-Chip tatsächlich teurer als ein Motorola-Chip?
Ja, deutlich. Man sieht der Kunde allerdings nicht so. Und zwar deswegen, weil...
Weil der Rechner billiger ist als ein...
Nee, auch gar nicht. Man könnte auch ganz billige Motorola-Chips bauen. Also Rechner mit Motorola-Chips. Aber Rechner werden immer erst dann billig, wenn sie in Massen produziert werden. Das heißt, was jetzt tatsächlich passiert, ist, dass Intel-Prozessoren eigentlich teurer sind. Und dass auch die Gehäuse und so, da haben sie sich auch lange Jahre nicht einigen können auf Standards. Und inzwischen gibt es da Standards, die sind auch sehr billig, weil die halt in riesigen Massen produziert werden. Und die ganzen Teile bei PCs sind echt billig, weil sie in Massen produziert werden. Und deswegen fällt der Prozessorpreis gar nicht so auf, der von einem heutigen PC über die Hälfte beträgt, was schon echt der Hammer ist, weil RAM ist echt billig geworden und ist also früher nicht vorstellbare Dimension, was wir heute an RAM in unseren Rechnern haben. Und die Motorola-Prozessoren sind eigentlich viel einfacher, so zu bauen, weil die Technik viel klarer ist. Die müssen viel weniger Ballast mit sich rumschleppen. Also eine Sache, die zum Beispiel echt offensichtlich ist, ist, dass bei Intel die Instruktionen nicht alle gleich lang sind. Das heißt, dass man, wenn man jetzt einen Prozessor baut, der zwei Multipliziere hat, und da sind jetzt zwei Multiplizierbefehle hintereinander, dann kann man den zweiten erst anfangen, sich anzugucken, nachdem man festgestellt hat, dass das erste Multiplizierbefehl ist. Weil erst dann weiß man, wie viel, wie lang der ist. Und dann weiß man noch erst, wann der zweite Befehl anfängt. Während bei anderen Prozessoren, Rüstprozessoren, sind die Befehle alle gleich lang. Das heißt, man kann sich die nächsten Befehle schon angucken, bevor man den gerade laufenden überhaupt angeguckt hat. Man kann also mehrere Befehle holen, auch gleichzeitig verteilt ausführen. Das wird nie gehen mit Intel. Und was gerade passiert, ist, dass da Tricks angewendet werden, wie das Intel einfach irgendwie 100 Befehle fetcht, also alle holt und dann versucht zu verteilen. Das ist ein unglaublicher Aufwand. Das kostet ein Schweinegeld auf dem Chip. Und das sieht der Kunde nicht, weil es in solchen Masten hergestellt wird. Und das ist echt eine Schweinerei und eine traurige Geschichte.
Wenn man Power-PCs in den Stückzahlen herstellen würde, wie Intel-Prozessoren, würden die vielleicht ein Drittel kosten. Bei gleicher Performance.
Und wir würden keinen Lüfter brauchen.
Was ist denn nachher in der Performance irgendwie der Unterschied?
Die sieht man eh nicht wegen Mind-Los normalerweise. Die Rechner sind eigentlich schnell.
Guck mal, die Kurve zurück zu den Embedded-Prozessoren zu kriegen. Was recht lustig ist, ist, dass man in Embedded-Prozessoren heute Taktraten findet, die halt früher für diese Prozessoren eigentlich nicht als eine Möglichkeit sind. Es gibt halt, man kann halt heute mit 120 MHz getaktete irgendwie Z280-Systeme kaufen. Da können wir gleich noch drauf kommen auf den Z280. Oder halt irgendwie Strong-Arm-Systeme, die halt auch mit mehreren 100 MHz laufen. Oder zum Beispiel, wenn man sich so den Amiga anguckt, wie viel MHz hatte der damals? 7, 0 irgendwas. Heute ist schon in jedem Pilot irgendwie 16 MHz, 68.000 drin. Also der halt irgendwie mehr als doppelt so schnell ist. Das ist halt irgendwie tatsächlich der Fortschritt von den Prozessor-Fabrikationstechnologien, der sich da halt bemerkbar macht. Da wird halt das Design an sich eingefroren und wird halt noch eine Wagenleitung an einer Ausgabegerätennummer umgebaut. Und dann geht's halt los mit Taktratnachrichten und so.
Eine Sache, die so ganz lustig ist, ist, dass man auch daran sehen kann, wie gut jemand Prozessoren bauen kann, kann man auch daran sehen, wie viel Wärme so ein Prozessor produziert. Und ein lustiges Beispiel, was mal vorgeführt wurde, war, dass ein Strongarm mit der Abwärme eines Pentiums betrieben wurde und ihn auch noch outperformt hat. Das heißt, er war auch noch schneller. Und so eine Sachen passieren eben. Und da fragt man sich doch, warum haben nicht alle Leute den Strongarm, wenn er so toll ist? Und die Antwort ist eben, weil der Windows nicht drauf läuft.
Aber eigentlich Hörer?
Zu welchem Thema?
Zu welchem Thema? Und zwar haben wir drei Fragen heute für die Hörer. Und die erste Frage, die wir ganz für unseren Hörern beantwortet haben wollen, ist, wie viele Computer gibt es in deiner Wohnung? Also jeder einzelne Prozessor in deiner Wohnung interessiert uns. Kannst du aufzählen, welche Systeme du schon als computerbehaftet identifiziert hast?
Wir können ja vielleicht an der Stelle sagen, das Ziel ist, dass unsere Hörer jetzt paranoid werden und überall kleine Prozessoren vermuten. Und der, der jetzt am meisten Prozessoren bei sich findet in der Wohnung, dem können wir vielleicht einen virtuellen Händedruck als Gewinn vermitteln.
Wir können das ja mal am Beispiel meiner Wohnung machen. Das ist unfair, weil da auch ein Büro drin ist. Aber sag mal, ich hab einen Desktop-Rechner, einen Laptop sind zwei.
Handy sind schon mal zwei CPUs. Das ist nämlich einmal der Micro-Controller, der das Ding steuert, und dann der DSP, der für die ganze Signalverarbeitung zuständig ist.
Okay, also bei vier. Verkauft. Verkauft.
Hast du ein ESDN-Telefon?
Überhaupt ein Telefon mit Display?
Nee, aber eine ESDN-Anlage, ist da was drin?
Überall eignet sich das nicht?
Einer, mindestens. Dann hast du noch den Controller in deinem NTBA, der an der Wand hängt, deine ESDN-Steckdose.
Das hat sogar zwei, also sind wir bei acht. Mikrowelle habe ich nicht.
Waschmaschine?
Waschmaschine? Sind wir bei neun. Was könnte denn noch sein? Herd und Ofen?
Versteuerte Heizungsangelegenheiten?
Offenheizung? Kohl?
Offenes Feuer?
Die Wohnung wird immer kleiner. Stereoanlage? So ein ganz super altes Teil, egal. Video-Kolle? Ja, alt, aber ist wahrscheinlich trotzdem mindestens einer drin. Fernseher? Ich hab so eine kleine Anlage, so ein Billigteil, da ist bestimmt auch einer drin.
Wo war ich zu Tageszeit? Sogar eine Fernbedienung, einer drin.
Fernseher?
12?
Dann lassen wir noch ein paar Sachen für die Hörer übrig.
Die Friss-Hotline ist geschaltet.
0331 für Postern. 7097110.
Die Telefonleitungen sind offen. Wir wollen von euch wissen, wieviel CPUs findet ihr in eurer Wohnung. Jetzt bitte auf den Boden kriechen. Ist ja bald Ostern, kann man statt Eiersuchen mal CPUs suchen. Wieviel Prozessoren also findet ihr in eurer Wohnung? In Computern und ähnlichem, das wir gerade schon angefangen haben aufzuzählen. Telefonnummer ist 0331 für Postern. 70 97 110. Wie viele Prozessoren findet ihr in eurer Wohnung?
Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Jo, wie heißt denn du? Marcel, hallo. Wie viele CPUs findest du bei dir? Die Frage hast du aber schon verstanden prinzipiell.
Nein, nicht ganz.
Okay, dann wiederholen wir sie erst nochmal, ja? Danke Marcel. Jo, es ist immer praktisch zuzuhören. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio. Wer ist da?
Hallo, Michael heißt.
Michael, hast du mal angefangen zu zählen?
Ja, ich hab angefangen, aber ich hab an der Stelle aufgehört, mir ist nämlich gerade aufgefallen, meine Eltern haben sich eine D-Box zugelegt. Und das ist ja nur auch eine spannende Sache. Sie haben gerade gesagt, im Battle System stürzt man in der Regel nicht ab, deswegen stürzt man aber wohl ab.
In der D-Box ist übrigens ein 68.340, also auch ein 68.000-Derivat. Und dann ist da noch eine MIPS-CPU auf dem Transportstream, die Multiplex hat drauf. Und dann ist da eine CPU auf dem ähm...
Keine weiteren Fragen, euer Ian.
Nee, es ist noch eine CPU auf dem Conditional Access Module, das für mich vollständig zuständig ist. Da ist noch ein Modem drauf, auf dem Modem ist auch noch eine CPU.
Und die Chipkarte.
Und die Chipkarte, auf der Chipkarte ist auch noch eine CPU. Also die D-Box zählt als fünf Prozessoren. Weiter.
Ein Gerät, wir können mal mitschreiben, ein Gerät, fünf Prozessoren, die D-Box ist im Moment definitiv Spitzenreiter. Michael, was hast du sonst noch gefunden?
Das, was ich schon aufgezählt hab, leider, naja, obwohl ein Herd ist ja auch noch dabei, da ist ja auch eine Digitalur drauf und die kann ja auch alles Mögliche, so dann noch Thermostat und so, wird ja auch alles davon gesteuert, also dieses Ding, was man in den Braten reinsteckt und dann sagt man einem, wenn er fertig ist.
Also den Kram, den ich aufgezählt hab, hast du auf alle Fälle auch.
Anrufbeantworter hat heutzutage natürlich auch Prozessoren.
Ja, die D-Box haut einfach raus.
Aber ein Auto, also D-Box kann ich konkurrieren mit Auto.
In der aktuellen S-Klasse sind glaube ich über 40 Mikrocontroller drin.
Ach.
So einbefangen beim ABS. 40 Stück? Über 40.
Deswegen sind die so teuer.
Nee, das ist noch das Billigste, die Programmierung.
Ja, ich glaube ich bin aber echt am Ende.
Was ist denn da die Gesamtwertung?
Moment, zwei NTBA, zwei ISDN-Anlage, fünf D-Box, acht, neun. ISDN-Telefon, zehn, Ampereit 11, diverse PCs. Ja, Moment, das sind ja auch mehr als eine drin wahrscheinlich. Das Ding auf der Soundkarte, das kann man ja auch noch einzeln anfangen.
Also sagen wir mal, PCs sind wirklich mittlerweile Multi-CPU-Systeme.
Ja, ich kann glaube ich für jede Festplatte mal eine CPU rechnen und für das CD-ROM natürlich auch.
Einiges Gasecontroller.
Genau, die Bus-Controller ist auch noch eine eigene CPU.
Ja, Interrupt-Controller.
Also ich glaube, auf 10 bis 15 CPUs kommen halt so einen durchschnittlichen PC schon, ne?
Ja, denke ich mal.
Aber das Einzelzählen ja langsam einwandhaft.
Naja, nicht wirklich.
Wir können ja PCs weglassen. PCs sind ja eh langweilig. Lass uns mal alles außer PCs nehmen. Du hast bestimmt einen Monitor mit On-Screen-Display, ne? Und deine D-Box stürzt du immer ab?
Ja, die ist tatsächlich noch nicht abgestürzt. Also auf einmal hat er auf nichts mehr reagiert, egal was man seitdem gedrückt hat.
Hast du an einen Schweinekanal geguckt?
Den nicht mal. Aber ich hab meinen kleinen Bruder dann bei der Hotline anrufen lassen. Und der hat dann halt empfohlen bekommen, ja so was passiert ab und zu mal ein Stecker rausziehen, wieder reinstecken. Also ausmachen, wieder anmachen.
Und hat's geholfen?
Computer erinnert. Ja, hat dann geholfen.
Du weißt mittlerweile, dass da fünf CPUs drin sind, wenn die irgendwie sich verheiratet.
Das ist übrigens ein ehrenes Prinzip bei Computern. Lässt sich auch gut zusammenfassen. Will der Router nicht routen, musst du boten.
Wofür ist das GASI-Anschluss an der D-Box eigentlich?
Na ja, ursprünglich war er dafür gedacht, dass man da einen CD-ROM einschließen konnte, um sich Video-CDs anzugucken. Mittlerweile haben sie das Feature aus der Software rausgeschmissen, weil sie den Platz für irgendwelche komischen On-Screen-Displays brauchten. Übrigens machen sie da das Software-Update über Satellit. Also man kauft sich diese Kiste und sie kann Video-CDs abspielen, dann fährt man zwei Wochen in den Urlaub, dann kann sie das plötzlich nicht mehr. Also eigentlich eine ziemliche Zumutung. Ja, mit der richtigen Software kann man da aber auch mittlerweile die Audiotracks auf eine Platte speichern und solche Geschichten.
Also die Software, die da derzeit drauf ist, ist nicht unbedingt, umgeht das, was man haben soll?
Übrigens das mit dem Booten und dann geht's wieder. Das funktioniert zwar fast immer, aber jetzt war gerade ein besonders peinliches Exemplar von Problemen, wo das nicht funktioniert hat, auf der CeBit. Da hat oder andere würde es vielleicht gelesen haben. Da hat nämlich die Eins versucht, eine Netzumstellung zu machen, nämlich Cell-Broadcast. Und daraufhin haben sich gewisse Nokia-Handys einfach permanent verabschiedet. Die sind dann in die ewigen Jahrgründe übergegangen. Und als ich das am CeBit Tag 1, wo es wohl eingeschaltet wurde, dann eher doch als peinlich erwies und sowohl Nokia-Stand als auch der Telekom-Stand überrannt wurden, haben sie das dann schnell wieder abgestellt.
Michael, wir gucken mal, ob dich noch irgendeiner toppen kann, okay? Dank dir. Unsere Nummer hier ist 0331. Wir podsten am 70 97 110. Wir suchen sämtliche CPUs in eurer Wohnung, außer die in euren PCs. Jo, wer bist du denn?
Hey, ich bin Boris.
Boris, hallo.
Da hab ich jetzt einen Sound gezogen. Ich hab vier, aber es zählt ja nicht. Scanner? Eine, zwei, drei.
Hast du einen Drucker?
Drei Stück, einen Postscript-Drucker.
Sag mal, hast du einen Computerladen?
Computerladen zählen nicht.
ISDN, ISDN-Anlage und ISDN-Telefon und aktive ISDN-Karte. ISDN-Karte gehört wieder zum PC, wa?
Naja, so kann man so sehen.
Okay, dann hab ich ein Oszilloskop.
Mindestens drei.
Mindestens drei würde ich denken, ja.
Tatsächlich selbst, aber Moment, bei so alten Oszilloskopen?
Nein, aber ein digitales.
Ein digitales Speicheroszilloskop.
Ja, okay, stimmt auch wieder.
Da sind die.
Also müssen wir mal aufschrauben.
Hast du nicht gerade Lust?
Hol doch mal einen Schraubenzieher. So ein ganz normaler Kreuzschlitz.
Und das Oszilloskop.
Erst den Stecker rausziehen.
Okay, Waschmaschine hab ich auch. Armband und Taschenrechner. Okay, C64, hier ist kein Computer zählt, aber trotzdem, oder?
Ja, die Floppy vom C64 hat natürlich auch eine CPU.
Nee, die hab ich leider nicht. Schade.
Interessanterweise war die fast genauso schnell wie der C64 selber. Es gab dann einige Fraktalprogramme, die die Floppy haben rechnen lassen.
Ja, die hatten ja auch den gleichen Prozessor. Und man konnte sogar, richtig, man konnte sogar seine C64 erweitern. Da konnte man aus dem Floppy-Controller noch einen zweiten User-Port basteln. Ach wirklich, das hab ich gemacht, das lief wunderbar. Da hatte ich so eine Lauflichtreihe von 16 LEDs, acht über C64 und acht über Floppy. Spaßige Sache. Na ja, wie alt war ich da? Sechs Jahre.
Guck an, was machst du heute so, wenn du bastelst?
Jetzt bastel ich gerade was ganz Banales. Und zwar eine Ansteuerung für eine Taschenlampe. Und zwar sind es so Taucherlampen, die brauchen dann, also für Taucherleute halt, die unter Wasser so irgendwie umtauchen. Und die brauchen dann halt Taschenlampen, die SOS-Signale blinken oder ein Signal geben, wenn die Batterie halb alle ist oder verschiedene Helligkeiten und, naja, so was halt. Was machst du denn da für Kontroller? Beruflich bin ich Zivildienstleister.
Achso, das war jetzt meine nächste Frage, weil das ja doch dann irgendwie sehr spezifisch...
Ja, und kostet doch Geld so ein digitales...
Ja, okay, ja, ich bau jetzt gerade die Steuerung für einen Herrn, der die restlichen Lampen baut. Und wenn er mit der Steuerung einfach gestanden ist, naja, dann wird ihm das Schaltbild verkauft.
Was nimmst du für einen Controller?
Wie bitte?
Also ich sollte jetzt für eine ganz einfache Billiglampe was machen, was möglichst ohne Controller ist. Da sind jetzt ein paar ganz billige Logik-Bausteine drin. Und für die teuerste Lampe wollte ich einen AV-R80 1200 nehmen.
Einen richtigen RIS-Controller, ja?
Weil recht einfach zu programmieren und so.
Es gibt jetzt sogar für Linux ein Assembler und eine Programmer-Software. Das heißt, man ist nicht mehr auf DOS angewiesen.
Ja, richtig. Und das finde ich auch echt gut. Aber hatte noch keine Zeit dafür, die bei mir raufzuspielen.
Kommst du denn zum Sommercamp?
Sommercamp? Ja, bis jetzt noch nicht.
Du sagst, das ist der 7. August in der Nähe von Berlin.
Rettungslampen brauchen wir da bestimmt.
Da brauchen wir echt eine Menge Leute, die irgendwie was von Controlern verstehen und so.
Und was wird im Sommercamp gemacht?
Na, das ist halt eine Hacker-Fehendag.
Drück die Uhr unter www.ccc.de.
Genau.
Da ist alles zu finden. Ansonsten, falls ich bei Franks so ein bisschen durchhör, dass da ein Kontakt gesucht wird, du kannst natürlich auch eine E-Mail-Adresse da lassen.
Also jetzt meine ich.
Na, dir ist aber recht peinlich.
Also, es kann nur zwei...
OL.
OL oder C online?
Nein, nein, nein, jahu.
Ist nicht peinlich.
Wir gehen mal auf, wir fahren nicht so. Warte mal, wir machen mal Musik. Wir können natürlich weiter anrufen.
Come with me to my music. Das ist eine würdige Anrufe.
Ja, Anrufer, die hier Lob kriegen, gibt's nicht viele. Also strengt euch mal an. Hallo, wer bist denn du? Ich bin der Ralf.
Ralf, hallo.
Hast du noch was drauf zu sagen? Wie viele Prozessoren sind in deiner S-Klasse? Ja, in der S-Klasse, weiß ich nicht, drei, vier vielleicht.
Alte Ente, da ist fast gar keiner drin.
Ja, aber in der Wohnung hab ich so einen jetzt zusammen gekriegt.
Schließ mal los.
Ja, also erstmal drei Stück für den Fernseher.
Drei Stück im Fernseher? Hast du da aufgeschraubt und nachgeguckt?
Ja, die sind im Fernseher und im einen sind wenigstens zwei hier drin. Fernbedienung mal mit eingerechnet schon. Dann hab ich 5-5 Video-Recorder, also besser für 2 mit Fernbedienung. Ja, dann haben wir einmal eine Kompaktsteher-Anlage, 2 für die Heizung.
2 für die Heizung?
Nein, eine Heizung selber und die Uhr, dieses Steuerteil da.
Dieser Regler ist auch elektronisch.
So, dann einen für die Chalazie-Steuerung.
Der kriegt einen Extra-Punkt.
Sag mal, hast du IP-Nummern vergeben bei dir?
Nee, verletzt sind sie nicht.
Ja, Anrufbeantworter hatten wir. Ja, dann haben wir eine etwas bessere Steheranlage. Das sind dann drei für Verstärker, Tape und CD.
Haben die Displays dann einen Extra-Tip? Nee, ich hab ganz an die Runde gefragt.
Die Displays werden meistens direkt aus den embedded CPUs getrieben. Die haben normalerweise die Flip-Controller an Bord.
Ja, also CD besser gesagt zweimal, weil da liegt noch irgendwo ein Discman in der Ecke. Dann haben wir einen Monitor mit Onscreen-Display. Dann hab ich zwei Amigas mit insgesamt drei Prozessoren.
Ach Gott, jetzt kommt hier die Halde im Keller.
Nee, nicht die Halde im Keller.
Die sind alle betriebsfähig.
Die steuern die Chalazien.
Etwas unterfordert, ja.
So, dann haben wir Molem mit dreien, wenn DSPs mitzählen.
DSPs zählen volle Kanne.
Ja klar.
DSPs sind heute mächtiger als die normalen CPUs.
Ja, eine LAN-4-Fernbedienung noch dazu.
So, was hab ich noch aufgeschrieben?
Dann hab ich eine selbstgebaute Monitor-Umschaltbox mit zwei Prozessoren. Also, es hat da einer 80C52-Derivat, also die AdMail ist hier, mit Flash und einer für die Tastatur-Interface, PC-Tastatur in Amiga und einer für die Umkleidung.
Na klar.
Was du mit dem Monitor-Umschalter betreiben kannst?
Um Platz zu sparen auf dem Tisch.
Aber so ein Elektrosmark machst du dir keine Sorgen, oder?
Überhaupt nicht, ne, nö.
Dann hab ich so drei Drucker in der Ecke zu stehen.
Wir nähern uns langsam der 50er-Grenze.
Dann haben wir auch so ein Handheld-OSSI, so ein Digitalspeicher-Scope.
Ach so, man kann ja vielleicht dazu sagen, Netzwerk-Interfaces-Andrucker haben natürlich nochmal einen extra Prozessor und extra Postscript-Kartuschen haben natürlich auch nochmal einen extra Prozessor.
So gut sind sie nicht. So, naja, natürlich Waschmaschine für Gefrihr-Kombi mit digitalen Anzeige.
Kann ich mal wissen, was du beruflich machst, bitte?
Ne, mich würde interessieren, wie groß ist die Wohnung?
Mich interessiert eher, wie keiner sich das alles leisten.
Naja, es ist nun unbedingt meine eigene Wohnung.
Du bist Geschäftsführer beim Media Markt.
Nein, nein.
War ja noch nicht zu Ende, ich war Schuhspüler.
Dann hatten wir noch ein Epom-Programmiergerät und ein 64er Samfloppy als Nostalgie-Projekt.
Wir waren fast 60, oder?
Ja, ich hab so nicht alliert, aber es könnte ungefähr hinkommen. Und dann sind noch so diverse Entwicklungssysteme für 80 C52-Dirivate und Prozessoren noch so in der Schublade und so.
Damit willst du doch bestimmt zum Camp kommen, oder?
Muss man mal sehen, ja.
Mit so einem riesen Wagen.
Also wir haben echt eine Menge Platz da. Wir holen dir ein großes Zelt und kommen einfach vorbei. Ralf war der Name, ne?
Okay, wir hören noch ein bisschen zu, Ralf.
Hm? Ähm, ich bin immer wieder erstaunt, wie viel Technik die Leute zu Hause haben.
Du hast so ziemlich wenig Kram, ich meine, dabei bist du doch so ein Gadget, man.
Ich bin ja komplett, ich bin wirklich völlig überrascht. Ich dachte, ich hätte viel.
Ich meine, das war doch irgendwie eine normale deutsche Grundausstattung.
Ach, wo, ich muss dazu sagen, bei mir liegen noch drei Newtons irgendwo rum.
Das sind doch bei sechs Bonuspunkte.
Das ist der zweite, der dritte.
Wie viele CPUs hast du eigentlich in der Hosentasche?
Das machen wir in der nächsten halben Stunde.
Nein, hier ist keine CPU drin.
Na klar ist da eine CPU drin. Da ist ein Rolling-Code-Generator drin.
Ist das von deinem komischen Auto, an diesem komischen Auto, was ich fahre?
Hast du immer noch dieses große Auto? Achso, da ist keine CPU drin.
Da kann man nachher live versteigern. Da ist definitiv keine CPU drin.
Aber du hast doch bestimmt Karten, oder? Du weißt schon so.
Stimmt.
Eine auf der EC-Karte.
Da ist schon mal ein Prozessor drauf. Und zwar in der Regel ein 6502.
Aber ansonsten auf den Karten glaube ich nicht. Nur Magnetstreifen.
Echt? Na gut, GSM-Karte?
IKEA-Firmkarte.
GSM-Karte.
Da ist natürlich drin.
Oh ja, genau, eine Handy-Szene sowieso.
Das ist wahrscheinlich zwei Telefone bei dir? Oder bist du auf eins downgraded?
Handys meinste? Naja, eins.
Na, da kann dir niemand mit Frank konkurrieren. Wie viel hast du dabei?
Komm, also ich hab nur... Ich hab nur ein Telefon und drei Karten, das ist doch nicht so viel, oder? Ja, genau, das ist nämlich die nächste Frage, die wir irgendwie...
Machen wir damit jetzt erstmal Schluss mit den...
Ja, genau.
Ich glaub, die Chalensivsteuerung oder Wörter noch einen.
Also einen nehmen wir noch.
Einen nehmen wir noch, genau. Und dann machen wir weiter mit den wie viele CPUs haben wir so am Körper?
Können vielleicht noch eine Sache...
Ach so, gut, ja, kann man ja vielleicht fließend einander übergehen lassen.
Noch eine Sache, vielleicht noch, was wir gerade tun, nennt sich Dick-Size-War. Genau, wenn jemand anruft und sagt, ich hab aber noch mir.
Wer hat den längsten? Machen wir einen ganz kurzen, ganz kurzen, du kannst natürlich auch Frauen anrufen, da geht's dann, wer hat den dicksten. Noch ganz kurz, weil es gleich einen Fritz-Kurz-Info gibt. Ansonsten, wie lang ist deiner?
Ja, nicht so lang wie der von eben.
Ah, das ist zumindest schon mal ein erdlicher Mensch.
Genau.
Da kommst du auch gar nicht drauf an. So eine kleine Kiste, die irgendeine Telefonnummer anzeigt. Genau.
Stimmt, es sind auch mindestens zwei.
Vermute ich.
Chronograph.
Armbanduhr mit Chronographfunktion, verschiedensten Funktionen, Zeigern, Wandern, Hin und Her und so.
Chronograph und Uhr nicht alle gleiche?
Heizungssteuerung. Direkt an der Heizung.
Kein System.
Akkuladegerät.
Und mit Display einstellen und so.
Das ist bestimmt ein 2-CPU-Gerät.
Ja, zwei Stück davon.
Also vier.
Ähm... Was hatte ich noch?
Kannst du mal grob abschätzen?
Funkuhr.
Da ist auf jeden Fall eine CPU drin.
Brotback-Automat.
Eine leckere CPU.
und außen Thermometer mit Speicher etc. Das braucht man doch.
Also ich muss zugeben, ich hab heute früh, als ich mir die Fragen für die Sendung ausgedacht habe, hab ich versucht, bei mir zu counten und ich hab bei etwas über 60 aufgehört. Da hatte ich noch nicht alle Schubladen durch.
Ein Label-Printer wollte ich noch erwähnen.
Was für ein Printer?
Ein Label-Printer, ja.
Garantiert auch so ein Waschmaschinen-Controller drin.
Gut, ich denke das war's.
Okay, dann danke ich dir.
Schönen Abend noch, tschüss.
Nach dem Kurz-Kurz-Info dann wie gesagt, die Frage, wie viele CPUs trägt man so am Körper mit sich rum? Und meine Favoriten gerade, definitiv der Brotback-Automat und der Chalazin-Steuerung. Es gibt so ein paar, es gibt bestimmt eine Menge Geschichten, wo CPUs drin sind und das hat keiner erwartet. Also wo man gar nicht wusste, dass da auch ein kleiner Prozess war drinsteckt. Und ich glaube von diesen Beispielen haben wir gerade schon einige gehört. Wenn man Furtz grad so schön geruft, kommt jetzt erstmal das hier.
Wenn Fritz im Raumanger mündet, dann 100, 1.
Es ist 0 Uhr 32.
Mobilmachung. Die Untergrundarmee Uchika hat am Abend alle Kosovo-Albaner zwischen 18 und 50 Jahren zu den Waffen gerufen. In einer Fernseherklärung hieß es, man wolle den serbischen Einheiten in der Krisenprovinz mehr Widerstand leisten. Kriegsspirale. Die NATO will ihre Luftangriffe gegen Jugoslawien ausweiten. Mögliche Ziele seien nun auch Regierungsgebäude in der Hauptstadt Belgrad hieß es in Brüssel. Die Einsätze sollen auch über Ostern fortgesetzt werden. Vermittlungsversuch. Eine hochrangige russische Parlamentariergruppe ist von Moskau nach Belgrad abgereist. Die Delegation wird vom Vize-Präsidenten der Duma Baburin angeführt. Nach seinen Worten hoffen die russischen Abgeordneten, den jugoslawischen Staatschef Milosevic zu einer Vereinbarung bewegen zu können. Aussage, die EU-Kommission hat keine Einwände mehr gegen die deutsche Öko-Steuer. Die Kommission werde demnächst ihre Zustimmung erzahlen, sagt ein EU-Sprecher in Brüssel. Die Öko-Steuer tritt morgen in Kraft. Fußball. Die deutsche Nationalmannschaft hat am Abend in Nürnberg das EM-Qualifikationsspiel gegen Finnland mit 2 zu 0 gewonnen. Die Tore schossen Jeremies und Neuville. Der amtierende Europameister übernahm mit dem Sieg die Tabellenführung in der Gruppe 3.
Wetter.
Heute Nacht gering bewirkt bei 6 bis 0 Grad am Tage nach Nebelauflösung, meist sonnig, Temperaturen 14 bis 18 Grad.
Verkehr.
A15 Richtung Cottbus. Zwischen dem Autobahn-Dreieck Spreewald und der Anschlusstelle Boblitz gefährdet ein defekter LKW den Verkehr. Wo kommt der wohl her, dieser LKW?
Im Verkehr.
Und dieser defekte LKW Richtung Cottbus.
Ach, ich fand's gut, meine sind ja noch schlechter. Gerrit Kötter-Einrich mit dem Fritz Kurzinfo.
Fritz präsentiert das Festival zur Erweiterung des Horizons. Afghan Wigs, Kinderzimmer Productions, die goldenen Zitrone, absolute Beginner, Slut, 1, 2 und hier die Sterne. Introducing 99 mit guten DJs, Stachi und Kotze von Fischmau, Touché von den Wise Guys und Mambo-Kurt als Konferencier. Introducing 99, Freitag, 2. April ab 19 Uhr in der Kolumbiahalle. Präsentiert von Fritz.
Und hier geht's weiter mit dem Chaos Radio Computerblumen bei Fritz jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat mit dem Chaos Computer Club. Heute dabei Frank, Andreas, Felix und Mike. Und mit Jonny am Mikrofon, mit euch im Chat unter www.fritz.de slash V-Chat. Und ihr könnt das live im Internet hören, falls ihr gar nicht in unserem Sendegebiet sitzt. Dann hört ihr mich natürlich jetzt nicht reden. Außer wenn ihr es schon live im Internet hört, aber dann bräuchte ich es euch nicht mehr sagen, weil ihr es ja schon wisst. Für alle die anderen, die im Netz sind und es vielleicht anderen sagen wollen, auf www.fritz.de gibt es den Link zum Real Audio Streaming. Wir hören gerade aus dem Chat, dass uns viele amerikanische Freunde zuhören, zum Beispiel von Cult of the Dead Cow. Und wir können jetzt praktisch hier mal so ein paar Greetings from Berlin rausschicken auf Englisch.
Wer möchte das dann von Chaos Computer Club übernehmen?
Ach nein, das ist doch zu peinlich. Johnny, du kannst doch am besten Englisch von uns allen.
You know, in Germany we don't have any, na, censorship, we can say what we want and we do it. Ich verfalle nimmer in so einem Monty Python Ton, wenn ich das hier spreche. Ah ja, also hier all das Beste aus Kurzemann-Germany sozusagen. Oh man, jetzt wird es leider wieder albern. Wir reden weiter mit euch, wir reden über Spezialcomputer. Wir haben gerade ein bisschen gezählt, wieviel CPUs, wieviel Prozessoren bei euch so zu Hause zu finden sind. Und jetzt gehen wir ans Eingemachte und fragen, wieviel tragt ihr gerade am Körper? Also, Handy ist klar, hatten wir schon, aber da gibt es natürlich noch einiges mehr. Und die Telefonnummer bleibt dieselbe, die lautet nämlich 0331 für Potsdam. 7097110. Wer ist denn da? Hallo? Enno, hallo? Wie viele CPUs befinden sich in unmittelbarer Nähe deines Körpers?
Also, zunächst mal zwei Handys.
Wofür brauchst du zwei Handys?
Einmal D-Netz, einmal D-Netz.
6 CPUs.
Wofür?
Hol dir doch mal ein Dual Band Handy.
Wofür ist die falsche Frage? Das ist eine Hacker-Sendung.
Na ja, das eine brauche ich.
Ich hab eine tolle Idee für ein Plakat. Kennt ihr dieses alte Antikriegsplakat mit den Soldaten? Ihr könnt ihm mal zwei Handys in die Hand geben und da drüber steht Why?
Ja, das eine ist nur mit so einer Korya-Card vorübergehend und das E-Netz-Handy ist mit einem Vertrag.
Und wer zahlt welchen? Papa zahlt den einen, Mama zahlt den anderen?
Nein, die Korya zahle ich selbst und den E-Plus-Vertrag zahlt mein Vater.
Also den benutzt du für Ferngespräche hier?
Auf meiner Lasse mich nur anrufen.
Okay, also ihr seid schon mal 16, Piro?
Dann Tamagotchi.
Nein, das ist ja wohl nicht zu glauben.
Ja, doch.
Ich hab irgendwie mit meinem Sohn neulich einen zerlegt, den ich noch irgendwo gefunden habe.
Obduziert heißt das.
Mit oder gegen deinen Sohn?
Mit meinem Sohn. Also zuerst wurde er in einem Wasserglas ersäuft und dann wurde er irgendwie zerlegt.
Wie alt war dein Sohn?
Nein, nein, nicht der Sohn, sondern die Pfanne.
Okay, weiter. Wie viel hattest du denn noch?
Ein Funkscanner.
Was für einen? Das hängt irgendwie vom Typ ab.
Bis 1, 8 Gigahertz mit Sprachentschlüsseler.
Nee, der Typ, weil davon hängt die Anzahl der CPUs ab.
Das wandelnde Datenblatt.
Zwei EC-Karten.
Ist da ein Chip drauf?
Ich mein schon, es wurde vorhin noch gesagt, dass auf jeder Karte ein Chip ist.
Na das siehst du so, da sieht es aus wie Telefonkarte, dieses Goldene in der Mitte. Da ist aber kein Prozessor drauf, sieht nur so aus.
Okay, dann hab ich so ein Handywarner, der los blinkt bevor das Handy klingelt.
Da ist keine CPU drin, das blanke Analog-Elektronik.
Ja, und noch eine Digital-Uhr mit diesen ganzen Sonderfunktionen, Höhenrechnung.
So, okay, lass uns mal zusammenzählen.
Ich hab vorhin auch eine Frage, trägst du Hosenträger? Wie hält das ganze Zeug in deinem Gürtel, ohne dass deine Hose runterrutscht?
Ich hab auch keine Hosenträger.
Also nicht so richtig ernst.
Und natürlich noch eine Datenbank. So eine kleine, aber nur mit, weiß nicht, 100 Einträgen oder sowas.
Na gut, aber die kommt auch nicht ohne CPU.
Wofür trägst du so einen Scanner mit dir rum?
Ja, ist manchmal ganz interessant, was man da so mitkriegt.
Ja, zum Beispiel.
Ja, das war's auch schon. Ich hab nicht mitgezählt.
Moment, also lass uns repetieren. Wir haben sechs in den Mobiltelefonen, zwei in den EC-Karten, einen in dem Funkscanner, eine in der Datenbank. Ähm, dort ist noch ein Timepilot, sagtest du?
Na, so eine Datenbank, so eine kleine.
Achso, und dann hat man noch eine digitale.
Das ist Tamagotchi.
Das ist Tamagotchi. Dann sind wir jetzt bei 12, genau, 12 CPUs.
Also das reicht aber noch nicht für irgendwie, dann noch nicht mehr für Erwähnungen. Ehrlich gesagt, Technobil hat noch deutlich mehr.
Dann kriegen wir noch ein bisschen mehr zusammen. Aber danke dir erstmal.
Tschüss, schönen Abend. Ich hab auch gerade mal gezählt. Ich hab festgestellt, ich hab mein Handy im Auto vergessen. Das heißt natürlich, dass ich echt gehandycapped bin. Aber, ähm...
Im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Ähm, ja, was haben wir denn da? Ein Pilot, da ist ein CPU drin. Dann hab ich, ähm, noch eine GSM-Karte extra einstecken. Und die IC-Karte sind also nochmal zwei.
Na, deine bionischen Handverstärker. Deine Schatzerbrille dahinter.
In der Funk-Uhr natürlich noch ein Prozessor 4. Also ich würd nur auf 7 kommen, das ist natürlich schwach.
Und hier kommt einer auf... Hello, über zwei telefonierst du gerade, wie man hören kann, ne?
Ich hab offenbar eine Uhr mit dem Datenbank.
Und dann hab ich noch hier so einen Swissphone-Funk-Wilderfänger.
Telefonkarten zählen nicht.
Aber zwei IC-Karten mit dem Schubdruck.
Dann hast du halt nur sechs CPUs an dir. Na ja, ich meine.
Ah, hat man grad schon das Doppelte.
Ist ja lame.
Nein, es geht ja nicht wirklich darum, jetzt anzugehen.
Nein, nein, nein, natürlich nicht.
Es geht darum, zu zeigen, mit wie viel Müll wir rumrennen.
Frank, erklär dich doch mal.
Ich danke dir schon mal. Ja, gute Fahrt noch.
Okay, wenn alles klar.
Thorsten, hallo.
Ja, Pager hat er mir gerade weggenommen. Und zwar hatte ich mal eine Zeit lang Pager, um nicht auszuprobieren, ob das was auf meinem PC dann ankommt, weil das genau dasselbe drauf steht wie da auf dem Pager.
Das dauert halt in der Regel nur lange. Normalerweise kommst du dann auch an irgendwann.
Ja, das ging ja eigentlich ganz fix.
Also irgendwie normalerweise, wenn du es übers Internet probierst, mit Paging, das dauert irgendwie so...
Nee, ich meine, ankommt stand dann dasselbe auf meinem PC wie auf dem Pager. Ich hab über Telefonnachricht abgeschickt, nur um das mal zu kontrollieren, ob dann dasselbe auch bei mir drauf steht.
Was echt gemein ist, wenn man das über Modem absetzt, ist, dass die Tarifierung erfolgt, unabhängig davon, ob der Ruf rausgegangen ist oder nicht.
Ja, sie können dir auch nicht garantieren, dass es ankommt, insofern muss das so sein.
Na ja, aber wenn du doch nicht mal da irgendwie Hello sagen kannst und dir schon irgendwie...
Klickt Gebührenimpuls, klick nach hinten, komm.
Dann machst du erst mal 1, 65 Mark weg oder so ähnlich und dann überlegen sie, ob sie mit dir reden.
In Amiland gibt es die glorige Erfindung des Two-Way-Pagers. Das ist ein Pager, der dann tatsächlich auch zurückmeldet, dass es erfolgreich angekommen ist. Warum die nicht gleich Handys verwenden, ist mir ein bisschen unklar.
In Starken ganz einfach, dass es für jemand zu teuer ist, weil du für Airtime zahlst immer noch.
Ja, stimmt, wahrscheinlich. Dafür ist das Internet da billig.
Du zahlst Airtime, du zahlst in Starken mit einem Funktelefon auch ankommende Gespräche. Du zahlst die Airtime, die dein Telefon benutzt. Das ist sehr viel teurer als hier.
Als wenn du permanent rumwürdest in der großen Klasse.
Also ist zumindest der Stand von vor...
Nee, ist immer noch so. Und wie geht es weiter? Was hast du noch an CPUs?
Ja, um das zu korrigieren. Wie gesagt, ich hab da auch über einen Funkempfänger die Datensignale, die dann audio-mäßig dann man ja auch mithört. Über die Soundkarte eingelesen und damit verarbeitet und damit dann auch...
Welche Software hast du genommen?
Was hab ich genommen? Da geht's immer noch nicht verstanden. Ist ein bisschen schlecht hier. Welche Software? Software, selbergeschriebene. Also ich hatte ein paar Befehle für die Soundkarte.
Nicht, dass wir jetzt hier irgendwie Probleme hätten mit der Anzahl der Leute, die kommen, aber... Hacker aller Länder vereinigt uns.
Also wir rechnen so eher mit 2500 Leuten, von daher ist genug Platz für alle.
Aber wie gesagt, ein paar Befehle. Drei, vier Befehle für die Soundkarte. Also praktisch den Wert wandeln und dann den auslesen an den Adressbereichen. Und wie gesagt, das erste war ein Auszieh, was ich gemacht habe über die Soundkarte zum Clean-It. Man kriegt eben nicht den großen Frequenzbereich damit hin. Sondern bloß, wie ihr seht, mit Samplingrate 44 Kilohertz. Kann man sich ja vorstellen, was man damit für Kurven hinkriegt, bis welchem Bereich die gehen. Und dann, wie gesagt, hat man von dem Funkempfänger den Audioausgang genommen und hat den da mit reingestöpselt. Und dann hier da hat man ein paar schöne Halbwellen, die man dann eben abtasten kann. Rein programmmäßig bearbeiten kann.
Und hast du die Singworte für die Pager auch hinbekommen?
Ja, da gibt es halt so eine Chaos Technical Library. Und da kann man ja alles nachlesen. Und das nächste war, wie gesagt, den Pager, diesen City-Rufempfänger hatte ich nur zeitweise, um das auch parallel anzugucken. Und dann hab ich jetzt hier, muss ich zum einen sagen, hier stehen 8031 und so ein kleines zweitsteiliges Grafikdisplay. Und damit wollte ich es gerade mal probieren, hardwaremäßig so ein bisschen zu machen. Also über einen Operationsverstärker die Audio-Signale, eben hardwaremäßig mit dem kleinen Controller einzulesen. Und wenn der noch einen Schritt weitergeht, dann vielleicht auch mal einen Empfänger zu basteln, dass ich diesen Funkempfänger, dieses Fertigen, dann nicht mehr mit für verwenden muss. So einen kleinen Empfänger mir selber basteln, wo dann alles eben zusammen ist.
Dann willst du ja sozusagen gerade einen Page abbauen. Dann wünschen wir dir noch viel Spaß am Gerät, würde ich sagen.
Tschüss, schönen Abend. Da freut sich doch das Hacker-Hertz, oder?
Da auch.
Da experimentiert jemand mit Besetzzeichen.
Hallo, wer ist denn da? Ich hab Handy, Alter.
Wäre noch...
Noch eins?
Tamagotchi.
Echt, wie viele Leute haben eigentlich noch ein Tamagotchi? Ich glaub auch gerade.
Ich dachte, die kauft es uns alle, um es dann auseinanderzunehmen, so für Forschungszwecke. Dafür kann man ja noch Geld dann ausgeben.
Elektronische Quälerei nennt man das.
Reine Forschungszwecke.
LCD-Spiel.
Was für ein kleines Schlüsselanhänger, oder was?
Und eine Telefonkarte ist zwar nicht zu. Und dann noch mal von vorhin, wegen heim CPUs. Da in die Menge.
Vom CD-Player.
Hast du noch was Neues?
Hast du was Neues, weil wir sind eigentlich jetzt gerade schon bei den persönlichen CPUs. Also nur wenn du wirklich originelle Dinge hast.
Als externes Gerät.
Da sind wir mindestens wie vier. Stimmt, das haben bestimmt viele.
Ah, da hab ich halt für mich bei mir...
Nicht, dass Johnny seine Zeit mit unproduktiven Spielereien verbringen will.
Ich werde link nach, Johnny.
Kriegt man sowas auch als Testgeräte, Johnny?
Erstaunlicherweise nicht. Ich hab mal einen Sega gekriegt vor ewiger Zeit.
Aber ich hab doch bei euch im Papierkoch gerade irgendwie Nintendo-Propaganda gesehen.
Dann kriegt man hier vielleicht Spiele als Testversion?
Ja, Propaganda kriegst du an Dauer. Spiele ist bei der Playstation auch extrem schwierig.
Die braucht man ja auch nur drei Wochen insofern. Das wäre doch optimal.
Ungefähr 30 Minuten.
Haben wir ja schon gesagt.
Du hast sozusagen einmal die komplette Palette. Hey, das ist doch noch ein Game Gear. Stimmt, da sind auch zwei drin ungefähr.
Eine Digitalkamera.
Ich muss gerade überlegen, kann man das nicht andersrum machen? In welchen Geräten die ich besitze, ist kein CPU? Dann komm ich.
Gründungssteuerung beim Auto?
Ja, ich meine, Autos sind halt eine spezielle Geschichte. Wenn man sich überlegt, Autotuning findet heutzutage nicht in der Stadt, dass man in eine Werkstatt fährt, da stöpselt ein freundlicher junger Mann in weißem Kittel sein Laptop ans Auto, spielt eine neue Software ein, optimiert den Zündzeitpunkt, und dann hat das Auto plötzlich 50 PS mehr. Das ist schon ganz schön scary. Man sich das überlegt, einfach so schwarze Software, die ist mittlerweile für BMWs.
Tobias, hast du noch etwas ganz Besonderes? Mit einem Keyboard zum Ansteuern auf dem Computer oder so?
Ja, mit MIDI-Stelle.
Ein MIDI-Keyboard. Da ist in der Tat eine CPU drin.
Radiosäcke wäre auch noch.
Stimmt, in den Dingen sind leider auch CPUs drin.
Denn ein MIDI-Keyboard ist eine CPU. Seit wann?
Um irgendwie die Daten, die da ankommen, auf die MIDI-Stelle zu schaufeln. Das machst du nicht mit vielen Tabletten. Ist kein Klavier, nicht mit Seiten und Hämmerchen.
Nee, ist schon klar, aber wieso brauchst du da eine CPU? Das ist ein elektrischer Impuls.
MIDI ist seriell, da kommen 8-bit-serielle Daten. Da kommen drei Bytes an, und aus drei Bytes irgendwie einen Ton zu machen, ohne eine CPU ist echt schwierig.
Ja, aber den Ton macht nicht das Keyboard.
Na, wer denn sonst?
Das Keyboard macht nicht den Ton, das Keyboard macht andere Sachen.
Na gut, wenn du ein Synthesizer hast. Dann musst du es halt umgekehrt machen. Dann musst du aus dem Tastendruck drei Bytes machen.
Du musst aus dem Tastendruck drei Bytes machen, natürlich. Das ist schwierig.
Na ja, da guck ich noch mal nach.
Tobias, quasi im Hintergrund immer noch.
Deine habe ich noch. Ja, Tobias, erzähl weiter.
Wir hören dir total enttäuscht jetzt zu.
Um wann läuft PC zum Fernseher?
Oh man, wann wurden die das letzte Mal gebaut?
Ja, die Monitore reichen nicht. Also irgendwo muss man weitermachen.
Du hast ein Problem, weißt du das?
Kein Problem.
Fünf?
Du hast sie wirklich alle aufgehoben.
Ja, dann hast du drei Drucker, Scanner.
Da ist nicht mehr Frage, was du mit deinen Computern machst?
Ja, mit den größeren schreib ich die Software. Und mit den älteren erstens alte Spiele noch spielen. Und dann noch Programme ausprobieren. Wegen DOS und so weiter.
Was schreibst du denn für Software?
Kleinere Spiele und irgendwelche Bereichenprogramme.
Professionell oder so für dich?
Ja, so für mich, privat. Denn der nächste, eine Pentium mit 120 zum Spielen noch ein bisschen. Und dann der etwas größere.
Hast du eine Freundin?
Wenn ja, wo? Das nennt man übrigens auch Vermüllung, wenn man das Zimmer nicht mehr verlassen kann.
Andere Jungs haben früher onlineiert, ich mein. Tobias, dank dir erstmal. Schönen Abend. Ach, wie ein Lustjahrabend heute hier. Ganz kurz mal. Super schön. Lass uns mal gleich auf so Spezialgeschichten kommen wie Autos und so weiter. Das finde ich eine ziemlich spannende Geschichte, was da so in Zukunft auf uns zukommt oder teilweise schon eingebaut ist. Was hast du vorhin gesagt? 40 CPUs sind in der S-Klasse drin?
Ungefähr, ja. Wir können ja mal durchgehen. Was ist denn da alles so drin? Also wenn man sich da reinsetzt, dann...
Also, warte mal, das fängt erstmal schon beim Keyless-Go an. Drahtlose Chipkarte irgendwie mit irgendwie Fizzle Fizzle, die dafür sorgt, dass du ob da reinkommst.
Stimmt, stimmt. Bevor man drin ist, hat man schon den ersten Prozessor aktiviert.
Haben wir schon ein bisschen Karten, wo man einfach nur aufmacht?
Da gehst du einfach dran vorbei und der macht die Klack und geht auf. Haben sie jetzt gerade eingeführt.
Ja und dann ist da natürlich...
Cool, oder?
Schnallt die S-Klasse dich eigentlich auch an oder machen das nur die US-Version? In Amiland gibt es Autos, da setzt du dich rein und... Schnallt dich das zu... Nein, nein, der macht wirklich davon zu. An der Tür fällt dann der Gott entlang und man setzt sich einfach hin und ist angeschnallt.
Das finde ich richtig geil.
Wie, man muss noch nicht mal klacken?
Nein, man muss überhaupt nichts machen. Der klackt vor allem.
Das hat aber einen riesen... Nee, der Gurt ist praktisch gespannt, wenn man jetzt als Fahrer sitzt, von rechts unten. Dann geht er quer rüber zur Tür.
Zum unteren Ansatz des...
Sobald die Tür aufgeht, läuft...
Der Windschutzscheibe unten links.
Genau. Laufen die nach vorne, diese beiden Gurtinnen, und wenn du die Tür wieder zumachst, dann laufen die nach hinten und klappen sich sozusagen über dich rüber. Und wenn du die Tür wieder aufmachst, dann laufen sie wieder rauf.
Da brauchen sie mindestens zwei CPUs für.
Das blöde ist nur, du wirst bei so einem Auto nie bei offenen Türen auf dem Fahrer sitzen können.
Na, das braucht man ja auch eigentlich eher selten.
Naja, wie gesagt, wenn meine Freundin hat, vielleicht schon.
Naja, aber die CPU ist im Auto. Die Motorelektronik braucht natürlich auch noch eine Handvoll, also um die Einspritzung anzusteuern und die Drehzahl zu regeln. Und die Katalysator-Steuerung, also wenn da ein Katalysator drin ist sowieso. Dann ABS, Anti-Schlupf-Regelung. Und dann gibt es ja irgendwie ESP, nennt sich das glaube ich.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ich sehe schon im Fest nicht so viel Auto, macht nichts.
Na ich fahr schon Auto, aber ich fahre noch eins, was auch nach MMP funktioniert.
Glaubst du Felix, glaubst du?
Na gut, glaub ich ja.
Das ist ein Franzosenauto, die haben da mit Absicht CPUs reingebaut.
Na ja und dann bei-
Das ist aber kein Franzosenauto, das ist ein Abanner.
Genau.
Und die sind hier offenbar auch noch vertreten, eine CA1620. Tja, ich weiß nicht, was die Leute hier so machen.
Ach ja, apropos CPUs in Mobiltelefonen. Es gibt einige Mobiltelefone, da ist im Akku eine CPU drin, damit man ja auch keine Nachbau-CPU da rein- kein Nachbau-Akku da drin verwenden kann.
Stimmt, da habt ihr schon mal was drüber erzählt.
Ja, dann baut man halt die CPU aus dem Akku ins Telefon um und gott ist. Naja, die sind irgendwie so groß, dass man sie nicht für CPUs hält mittlerweile.
Überhaupt eine Sache noch, wenn man heutzutage CPUs kauft oder sieht, wenn man seinen Rechner aufbaut, dann ist ein riesen CPU drauf, die ist irgendwie deutlich über einen Quadratzentimeter groß und man denkt, wunder, was das alles für Technik ist. Aber wenn man da tatsächlich oben die Silicium-Schicht abbaut, dann stellt man fest, dass die tatsächlichen Chip-Ausmaße deutlich geringer sind. Der ist nur so ein großes Silicium-Claps drumrum, weil man die Beinchen ansonsten schlecht ausfüllen kann. Also da eigentlich die Chip gewöhnlich nur so zwischen 1, 2, manchmal 3 Quadratzentimeter.
Du hast vorhin so nette Geschichten erzählt über die Zukunft des Autos mit CPU. Da hat sicher vielleicht jeder, der sich halbwegs dafür interessiert, schon mal darüber gelesen, dass man natürlich sowas wie Motorenleistung, wo heutzutage bei den meisten Autos tatsächlich ja noch verschiedene Motoren dann in den verschiedenen Modellen drin sind, das ist Vergangenheit. Weil eigentlich so ein Motor dann nur noch besteht aus einem entsprechenden...
Nein, nee, also es ist so, dass die Motorleistung hängt ja von vielen verschiedenen Parametern ab. Und heutzutage ist es halt so, dass die Autos, das ist halt ein Trade-Off, so wie die eingestellt werden. Also man kann halt irgendwie sagen, ok, man fährt halt den Motor so und so viel Prozent der Vollbelastung aus mit der Motorsteuerung, das heißt also so knapp wie man schaltet oder dass wir sich automatisch schalten, zum Beispiel sind ja auch mal das in zwei CPU-Systemen. Und man kann halt diese, diese, diese Einstellungen halt ändern. Das heißt man ändert die Motorparameter, man ändert den Zündzeitpunkt ein bisschen, man ändert das Einsportvolumen ein bisschen und so weiter und so fort und kriegt dann dadurch mehr Leistung aus dem Motor raus, erhöht aber auch den Verschleiß. Andersrum kann man natürlich auch den Motor ein bisschen ökonomischer fahren, indem man halt sagt, okay, ich brauche jetzt irgendwie keine 95.000 PS, sondern ich brauche halt nur 95. Und fährt halt die Leistung ein bisschen runter und kann damit seinen Motor auch ein bisschen länger betreiben. Aber ich glaube irgendwie Öko-Tuning habe ich noch nur irgendwo gesehen für Autos.
Nee, aber es geht doch um eine Leistung und vor allen Dingen auch um Preis. Dass du eigentlich nicht mehr, heute bildet man sich ja noch ein, weiß ich nicht, nehmen wir mal an, Modell XY gibt es mit 60, 100 und 160 PS.
Da sind tatsächlich noch andere Motoren drin. Also diese Motorlassungsänderung, dieses Tuning sind oft noch ja so Sachen wie in den großen Autos ist ja heutzutage eine elektronische Abregelung bei 250 kmh drin. Es hat so eine freiwillige Selbstkontrollvereinbarung, dass sie halt sagen, okay, man kann halt kein Serienauto kaufen, was halt schnell 250 fährt.
Versteht man nicht, oder?
Und dann geht man halt irgendwie zu irgendeinem Tuner und die nehmen dann halt dieses Bit raus, was halt sagt, bei 250 elektronisch abregeln. Und dann kann man halt auch noch mit 310 gegen den Brückenpfeiler fetzen, wenn der Motor groß gemacht wird.
Dann muss man sich nur noch einen neuen Tacho einkleben lassen, der mit dahin geht.
Na, dem mit Tacho ist ja meistens elektronisch mittlerweile. Naja, was auch interessant ist, ist, dass in den Autos mittlerweile auch, was weiß ich zum Beispiel, BMW ist wieder ein klasse Beispiel dafür, da sind halt mittlerweile Speicher drin, die das Fahrverhalten speichern. Das heißt also, in der Bedienungseinheitung steht halt so, in den ersten 2000 Kilometern sollten sie irgendwie nie länger als 15 Sekunden über 110 fahren oder so ähnlich. Und da ist ein Speicher drin, der tatsächlich diese Spitzenwerte speichert. Das heißt also, wenn du in den ersten 1000 Kilometern halt irgendwie ordentlich auf der Autobahn rumbrätst und dann fährst du in die Werkstatt, weil der Motor klappert, dann steckt da sein Laptop ran, guckt sich die Kurve an und sagt dir, wissen Sie, am 27. sind sie um 1352 185 gefahren. Das irgendwie hat ihre Garantie violated. Also sie haben jetzt hier irgendwie leider ein Problem. Und was man dann halt tut, ist, wenn man das getan hat, man fährt halt vorher zu einem anderen Schrauber, lässt sich halt diesen Speicher halt zurücksetzen und hat dann halt irgendwie eine schöne, saubere Kurve, die halt dann irgendwie noch die Garantie garantiert.
Sie sind ja noch gar nicht gefahren mit dem Auto.
Wie sind Sie denn hergekommen? Wie sind Sie denn hergekommen? Es gibt tatsächlich, also das ist wirklich die Rache der Nerds. Also selbst der Autoschrauber wird irgendwann ersetzt werden durch den Computerfachmann. Also dein Sohn kann dann wahrscheinlich dein Auto tunen.
Also mein Auto ist garantiert 100% cpu-freund.
Da ist auch nichts mehr zu tunen.
Da ist auch nichts mehr zu tunen irgendwie.
Dafür kann man bequem zu acht damit in den Urlaub fahren.
Genau.
Man kann vielleicht sagen, dieser Trend, das ist natürlich...
Du hast ein Fahrrad mit ganz vielen Sitzen.
Ne, ich hab so ein fettes Wohnmobil, so ein altes Dublin-Teil.
Also für den Hersteller ist das natürlich eigentlich wünschenswert, nur eine Art von Motor zu haben, weil die Fertigung dann viel billiger wird und da dann später einzustellen. Und das ist natürlich nur dann schlecht, wenn sich das rumspricht und Tuner, Buden gibt, die das eben günstig umbauen. Und lustigerweise war das am Anfang der Computergeschichte richtig üblich, dass man Rechner dann per Software geupgradet hat. Oder so eine der lustigsten Anekdoten aus der Geschichte war das IBM früher für Großrechner. Diese Waschmaschinen, Schraubfestplatten verkauft hat, die also noch richtig Festplatten waren. Und die gab es dann in drei Größen, nämlich 11, 22 und 33 Megabyte. Und die konnte man dann eben upgraden lassen. Und dann kam so ein IBM Mensch und der hat die aufgeschraubt und hat so Arretierungen an dem Kopfhalter verschoben, so aufgeschraubt, ein bisschen nach links geschoben. Und dann hat er halt mehr Platz gehabt, wo er sich bewegen konnte. Und dann war eben mehr Platz. Und durchschnittliche Rechnerbetrieb hat es eben akzeptiert, weil es eben IBM, es gibt niemand anders, der für IBM Festplatten hergestellt hat. Und wenn sich das rumspricht hat IBM natürlich verloren. Aber sowas war durchaus üblich. Und es gab auch Zeiten, da haben die Hersteller Hardware-Upgrades verkauft, die in Wirklichkeit Software-Upgrades waren. Der Deck hat es das mal passiert. Da haben die auf ihren Prozessoren damals noch alles sehr CISC orientierte Systeme, die ja so hunderte von Instruktionen hatten, die dann alle irgendwelche Spezialsachen erlaubten, so völlig obskur für heutige Programmierer gar nicht mehr nachzuvollziehen. So Sachen wie, füge ein Element in eine Prioritätswarteschlange ein. Das ist eine Sache, die programmiert man heutzutage selbst. Das lernt man an der Uni, wie man das tut. Und das ist auch gar nicht so trivial. Aber es gibt einen Grund, warum man das haben will. Weil dann die Programmierung von einem Multi-CPU-System einfacher wird. Deswegen ist das damals eben da gewesen. Dieser Befehl war hinreichend komplex, dass er dann auch hunderte bis zu tausende Vontakten gebraucht hat. Und eine solche Instruktion war, kopiere eine Zeichenkette von hier nach da. Das ist eine Sache, die wird sehr häufig gemacht. Das ist eine der häufigsten Operationen in Programmen heutzutage. Und diese Instruktion war tatsächlich viel langsamer, als wenn man das von Hand kopiert hat. Und das ist eines Tages aufgefallen. Und dann hat DEC ein System-Update verkauft, was eben in dem Betriebssystem diese Routine geändert hat, die eine Zeichenkette kopiert, sodass sie nicht diesen Befehl benutzt, sondern es von Hand macht. Und dann ist eben so ein durchschnittlicher, lastig, glaube ich, 30 Prozent Performance bei dem Prozessor gewonnen worden, bei den Maschinen. Und die Kunden freuen sich natürlich, weil das ist ja dieser kleine Eingriff, da muss man irgendwie nicht schrauben. Also sowas gab es zuhauf früher. Und heute ist das natürlich, heute wo es so viele graue Schrauber gibt auf dem Markt, da werden ja schon Prozessoren umgelabelt. Also wenn wir mit solcher Art von Kriminalität zu tun haben, kann man so eine Dinge natürlich nicht drehen, weil sobald das einer erfährt oder sobald einer entlassen wird und mit seinem Gehalt nicht zufrieden ist, was ja heute durchaus gängig ist, wenn man sich anguckt, was Leute in so Chip-Fabriken verdienen. Also gerade Intel hat gerade wieder mehrere tausend Leute gefeuert, das kommt eben vor. Und da kann man sich das nicht mehr leisten.
Was mich schon interessiert in dem ganzen Zusammenhang, wenn man sagt, wir reden nicht über Kühlschränke und so, wir haben von Embedded Systems gehört, in Geräten, wo es wahrscheinlich jemand, der sich nicht so eng damit auseinandersetzt, nicht erwartet hat. Also, weiß nicht, wie viele Leute wissen, dass an der Waschmaschine auch eine CPU ist? Weil die hat ja auch vorher funktioniert, die gab es ja auch mal ohne CPU. Und gut, die ist jetzt elektronisch geregelt. Was kommt da auf uns zu? Also wie viele CPUs werden wir in Zukunft mit uns rumtragen? In welchen Geräten? Was wird bei uns zu Hause rumstehen? Und damit man jetzt nicht nur die, die sich dann irgendwie die super teuren Geräte leisten können, sondern irgendwann, das wissen wir alle, ist das komplett normal, bestimmte Sachen. Die sind dann einfach, wenn du eine Waschmaschine kaufst, ist da auch ein Prozessor drin. Gibt gar keine mehr ohne.
Also es gibt heutzutage gerade noch so eben Waschmaschinen ohne Mikroprozessor, die halt noch mit so einer mechanischen Drehablaufstörung funktionieren. Aber ich denke, du wirst dich nicht noch länger als irgendwie 1 oder 2 Jahre hinziehen. Also die größte Inflation von CPU-Zunahme sehen wir halt ziemlich eindeutig im Chipkartenbereich. Also so in den letzten Jahren hat Karten, die man so durchschnittlich mit sich rumträgt, irgendwie ziemlich zugenommen. Und Chipkarten wären auch so allgemein als irgendwie das Silver Bullet angesehen, das man halt benutzt, um irgendwie Sicherheitsprobleme zu lösen. Was dann aber doch irgendwie sich mittlerweile als Fehler herausgestellt hat.
Ja, letzte Woche war nämlich die AES-Konferenz in Rom. AES ist der designierte Nachfolger von DES, den Data Encryption Standard. Dann gab es halt eine Handvoll Proposals für neue Verschlüsselungsverfahren aus aller Welt.
Sag doch mal, wieviel für das A in AES steht.
Für Advanced. Genau, Advanced.
Und vorher das D Stand für Decreased, oder?
Data Encryption Standard.
Genau, und AES ist jetzt der Advanced Encryption Standard.
Genau, mit Extended, Expanded und...
Genau, so eine Abkürzung gibt es viele Tausende in der Computerbranche und da freuen sich die Hacker auch immer gerne.
Na ja, auf jeden Fall gab es da einen Haufen Vorschläge und sie haben sich diese Vorschläge angeguckt und nach verschiedenen Kriterien bewertet. Und unter anderem gab es halt eine Analyse, wenn man diese Algorithmen auf Chipkarten verwendet, ob das dann sicher sei. Es gibt halt ein Verfahren, das nennt sich Differential Power Analysis. Was man da macht, ist im Prinzip zu gucken, wie viel Strom diese Chipkarte verbraucht, wenn sie eine bestimmte Operation durchführt. Und das Ergebnis war, dass Chipkarten leider völlig ungeeignet für Sicherheit sind, weil bei allen Verfahren, die sie untersucht haben, sich mithilfe dieser Power Analysis der Key extrahieren lässt. Das heißt, Chipkarten sind unsicher, Chipkarten sind nicht tauglich und ich denke, wer auf Chipkarten setzt, begeht Fehler.
Sagst du vielleicht noch was dazu, wie diese Analyse funktioniert so über den Damen?
Na ja, im Wesentlichen ist es eine statistische Analyse. Das heißt, man lässt die Chipkarte rechnen, man schickt halt Daten hin, dann macht das Ding was, schickt wieder Daten zurück, man guckt sich an, wie die Stromverbrauchskurve dabei aussieht und man macht da mehrere hundert Messungen und nimmt dann den Durchschnitt dieser Messungen.
Vielleicht an der Stelle andere Verfahren, die als kritisch für Verschlüsselungssachen bewertet wurden, haben so ein paar Millionen Angriffe gebraucht, bis sie überhaupt Informationen extrahieren konnten. Also dieses Verfahren braucht einige hundert, das ist lachhaft wenig.
Der Punkt ist halt, dass man da das Rauschen rausmittelt und am letzten Ende ist in der Lage, erst den Stromverbrauch eines einzelnen Transistors zu messen, der in dieser CPU drinne steckt. Das heißt, man kann messen, ob da eine 0 oder eine 1 reingeschrieben wurde. Und das ist dann halt...
Bei Chipkarten und Sicherheit gehen wir jetzt mal davon aus, dass zum Beispiel, es gibt ja inzwischen Computer-Keyboards mit so einem Lesedingstück, zum Beispiel Homebanking, bla, und das dann aber mit der Karte als Sicherung und nicht einfach nur eine PIN, die abgefangen werden könnte.
Na, der Punkt ist ja...
Wer kann denn wo den abfangen? Wie viel Strom hat diese Karte da vor Ort?
Na, nehmen wir an, hier Fritz hat doch dieses großartige Sicherheitssystem, wo alle Mitarbeiter nur mit einer Chipkarte reinkommen, wo eben ein Schlüssel drauf ist.
Ich hab keine.
Na gut, nehmen wir doch mal an. Ja, nehmen wir doch mal an, es gäbe sowas, dann könnte ein Hacker... Ja genau, dann könnte ein Hacker kommen und könnte dieses Gerät ein bisschen manipulieren, sodass die Karte, die man reinsteckt, eben untersucht wird. Der User merkt, 100 Angriffe ist so wenig, dass das in, weiß nicht, unter einer Sekunde oder so gemacht wird. Oder selbst wenn es ein paar Sekunden dauert, das merkt der User ja nicht. Oder was noch viel schlimmer ist, wenn man das Portemonnaie mal kurz entwendet, während derjenige pinkeln ist, dann kann man schnell den Key rausholen und ihm die Karte zurückgeben. Und er merkt halt gar nicht, dass er jetzt nicht mehr der Einzige ist, der mit dieser Karte einrichten, also irgendwo reingehen kann. Man kann diese Karten eben herstellen und was momentan, worauf die Sicherheit dieser Systeme basiert, ist, dass auf der Karte ein geheimer Schlüssel drauf ist, den man eben nicht auslesen kann, sondern man kann nur die Karte fragen, wenn du diese und jene Operation damit machst, ist das Ergebnis dieses. Sowas kann man machen. Und das heißt, dass man den Schlüssel eben ausprobieren müsste und dazu ist die Schlüssellänge zu lang und die Karten zu langsam. Aber wenn man den jetzt auf diese andere Methode rausholen kann, dann kann ich zum Chip-Händer an die Ecke gehen, mir eine Karte herstellen lassen, wo dann auch ich überall reinkomme, wo deine Karte dich reingelassen hätte. Und das heißt unter anderem EC-Karten, die auf Chip-Karten basieren sollen oder sonst irgendwelche Systeme, im Grunde damit zu klangbaren.
Handy-Karten, Zugangskontrollkarten, was es nicht alles gibt.
Was kommt da als Alternative auf uns zu?
Tja, ist noch schwer abzusehen.
Biometrie funktioniert ja auch nicht.
Also momentan ist das ein Problem.
Was ist mit diesen ganzen Fingerabdruck, Augen-Scan und so weiter? Körperteile?
Die haben halt grundsätzliche Probleme, wenn du so ein Fingerabdrücke denkst. Meine Fingerabdrücke hinterlässt man halt überall.
Also abgesehen von ganz anderen Problemen, die ich mir vorstelle dabei, wenn man...
Ich meine gerade, in Osteuropa sollte man, glaube ich, vom Ansatz von Biometrie erst mal auf etliche Zeit absehen. Da haben wir irgendwie Belustigungen bei den Pathologen, die dann halt wie seltsame Opfer da sind. Wie auch immer.
Wir könnten vielleicht noch eine Sache erwähnen. Es ist auch so, dass die Prozessoren so günstig geworden sind, dass es sich auch anbietet, inzwischen Systeme zu bauen, die nur noch arbeiten mit Prozessoren, die eigentlich auch so gebaut werden hätten können. Also es gibt jetzt Flugzeuge, die gar nicht mehr fliegen würden von der Konstruktion her, wenn die Computer ausfallen, sondern da braucht man dann eben Regelcomputer, die gegensteuern, damit das Ganze wie ein sauberer Flug wirkt. Und es gibt Gründe, die eben dazu zwingen würden, dass man das Flugzeug dann anders baut und solche Konstruktionen werden dann möglich. Das heißt dann natürlich auch, wenn der Computer dann doch mal ausfällt, dass man eben sofort irgendwie abstürzt. Und deswegen muss man halt den Computer dann mehrfach einbauen. Aber solche Sachen sind eben dann heutzutage reichen Rücken in Akten. Weil die Programmierung ist eine Sache, die man eben nur einmal bezahlen muss. Und danach kann man das auf alle Chipkarten oder alle Devices kopieren, die die Leute kaufen. Deswegen ist immer die Programmierung so einer der schwersten Teil der Forschung überhaupt in der Entwicklung von solchen Geräten.
Ihr hört Chaosradio. Jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat gibt's hier bei Frips den Computer-Bumon mit dem Chaos Computer Club, denn danach ist auch die Sendung benannt, mit Johnniermikrofon und mit verschiedenen Spezialthemen. Heute ist das Spezialthema Spezialcomputer und wir haben über verschiedene Embedded Systems geredet, also über eingebettete Prozessoren in Geräten, die nicht der PC sind, die auf euren Tischen stehen und mit Monitoren verbunden sind, sondern zum Beispiel Waschmaschinen, Handys, alles sowas. Und im Moment sind wir angelangt bei, bzw. wir kommen jetzt zu dem Punkt außergewöhnliche Autos für CPUs bzw. für Embedded Systems.
Ja, also die halt interessante Eigenschaften haben, da schmeißt man 50 Pfennig rein, dann geht die Tür auf, dann kann man sein Geschäft verrichten. Wenn man halt zu lange braucht, geht nach 15 oder 20 Minuten automatisch die Tür auf, da wird man dann automatisiert rausgeschmissen. Dann, wenn die Tür wieder zu ist, also wenn man halt rausgegangen ist, was mit einem Bewegungsmittel überprüft wird, wird das halt automatisch alles durchgespült, sauber gemacht, irgendwie eine neue Plastiküte über die Klobewelle gezogen und so weiter, halt alles vollständig automatisiert.
Wie viele CPUs braucht man dafür?
Also ich schätze, es ist so vier, fünf CPUs sind da schon drinnen. Es könnte auch gut sein, dass es irgendwie von Siemens ist, dann haben sie dann eine speicherprogrammierbare Steuerung genommen und wahrscheinlich so viel dafür bezahlt, dass man eine Ausgangsschlußung dafür kaufen kann. Naja, ich weiß, die Japaner haben es noch ein bisschen mehr übertrieben, da gibt es halt so...
Weiß ich nicht. Hat man vor fünf Jahren geglaubt, dass das Internet den Stellenwert hat, den es jetzt schon hat? Es wäre immer eine Frage der Zeit, ob man die einschätzen kann. Aber glaubt ihr, dass so eine Geschichte zum Beispiel, weiß ich nicht, Urinprobe morgens gleich, das macht die Toilette selbstständig, prüft da eine Werte, wenn die nicht stimmen, dann gibt es eine kurze Meldung an den Hausarzt, der ruft an oder weiß ich nicht.
Also ich denke, dass irgendwie viel mehr, sag ich jetzt mal, ein Standalone-System passieren wird und dass diese Vernetzung von diesen Embedded-Systemen zumindest in Deutschland langsamer sein wird, als jetzt irgendwie so behauptet wird. Weil da hängt halt auch eine ganze Menge Privacy dran und letzten Endes möchte man halt einfach nicht irgendwie, dass man sich erstmal eine Firewall konfigurieren muss, damit man sicher sein kann, dass nicht irgendein Hacker die Klo-Spülung auslöst, wenn man gerade auf dem Klo sitzt, weil darauf läuft die Sache halt letzten Endes hinaus.
Oder deine Blutwerte verändert.
Oder einen gewohnt und halt irgendwie nicht jeder Crack da letztendlich alles gekauft hat.
Das finde ich schon interessant, eine vage These, dass da halt ein Gefühl für Sinnhaftigkeit...
Vor allem, dass nicht jeder Scheiß gekauft wird, das ist einfach widerspricht der Erfahrung.
Ja, manchmal glaube ich sogar auch. Manchmal bin ich halt ein bisschen optimistisch aus.
Ich bin schon immer...
Ich freue mich, dass man ja vorhin auch kurz gefragt hat, was macht jemand mit fünf, sechs Computern zu Hause, der damit nicht beruflich zu tun hat? Was macht der damit? Wir gehen mal am Wochenende und zurzeit kann ich halt wirklich nur samstags irgendwie, dass ich nicht einkaufen gehe oder so, weil das die einzige Zeit ist, die ich habe. Und dann gehst du irgendwie, bist in einem Kaufhaus und die Leute schleppen Scanner und Drucker irgendwie en masse nach Hause.
Was ist cool, man?
Ich meine, die Leute entdecken halt mittlerweile, dass irgendwie Schreibmaschinen out sind. Was auch immer für eine spezifische Anwendung, so weil sie irgendwie dieses und jenes Programm fahren wollen oder weil sie halt irgendwie dieses oder jenes Sache ausdrucken wollen, was ist das? Ich meine, mittlerweile kostet irgendwie so ein Tintenpisserdrucker irgendwie vielleicht noch 200 Mark. Den kauft man sich schon mal, wenn man gerade mal eine Diplomarbeit ausdruckt.
Der kostet ungefähr genauso viel wie die Patrone hier.
Ja, ich meine, hinterher ist der Drucker, also nach einer Diplomarbeit, ist ein durchschnittlicher Tintenstrahldrucker sowieso im Eimer. Von daher ist der Preis durchaus angemessen, aber naja, also ich denke schon, dass irgendwie so Special-Purpose-Geräte, also Geräte, die halt einen speziellen Zweck erfüllen, halt immer mehr irgendwie um sich grafen. Wenn man sich so anguckt, Diktilgeräte mittlerweile sind mittlerweile digitale Angelegenheiten. Die gibt's nun auch schon mit irgendwie Voice Recognition. Da stöpselt man hinterher einfach so ein Diktilgerät an den PC ran und dann wurstelt er sich irgendwie durch das Gekrechze durch und macht da hinterher ein lesebaren Text raus oder so was Ähnliches zumindest. Nur für Windows und das mag ich dann nicht. Und es funktioniert irgendwie doch erstaunlich gut für so irgendwie so ein Early Bird Gerät. Also hat mich doch irgendwie beeindruckt. Also Spracherkennung ist sowieso noch so ein Ding. Mittlerweile ist Spracherkennung ja in Mobiltelefonen drin. Also Voice Style haben halt eigentlich alle aktuelleren, neueren Mobiltelefone, die jetzt so gerade auf den Markt kommen.
Aber ist das tatsächlich eine Spracherkennung?
Also es unterscheidet sich tatsächlich von dem, was man früher so hatte. Da gab es halt irgendwie so Ja-Nein-Erkennung so. Die hieß dann im Fachkreis auch Grunds Detection. Man konnte halt irgendwie sagen Sie jetzt bitte Ja, wenn Sie irgendwie dieses Minus wollen. Dann haben wir es gemacht und dann haben wir gesagt Sie haben Ja gesagt. Also das war halt so die erste Generation so nach der Spracherkennung. Und mittlerweile ist die Sache doch schon deutlich fortgeschritten. Also es gibt halt irgendwie schon richtig gute Systeme.
Ich hab so gesagt hast, wie du ihn vorher auch donnerst. Also musst du ja diese Nummer eingeben. Also eine echte Spracherkennung wäre zum Beispiel für mich, wenn ich den Namen eingetippt hab im Handy. Wenn ich sage, weiß ich nicht, Fritz. Und da ist dann 0331 und so weiter. Und ich hab Spracherkennendruck auf der Tasse, sage Fritz und das erkennt er dann.
Also was die in diesem Philips Teil drin haben, ist halt so eine Art Fuzzy-Logic, die halt einfach geringfügige Abweichungen in deiner Sprache ignoriert und halt einfach das Muster erkennt. Mittlerweile, ich glaube in dem neuesten Motorola, ist halt eine Nummernerkennung drin, also da kannst du halt die Telefonnummer sagen. Träumende Kraft dahinter ist natürlich, dass die Leute halt während des Fahrums telefonieren wollen, ohne halt die Hände vom Lenker zu nehmen. Das ist auch richtig vernünftig.
Na, das soll ja auch gesetzt werden, dass du nicht mehr mithalten.
Ja, ich meine das ist eigentlich ziemlich vernünftig, weil dann gewöhnen sich die Leute langsam an Hats herz und dann wird nicht mehr angeguckt wie ein Alien. Durch die ganzen Leute, die komisch gucken, kann ich mir den ausblenden.
Gibt's das mit deinem Datenhandschuh?
Die werden halt weggerendert.
Genau, ich brauche das für morgens für die U-Bahn.
So eine Brille wäre doch zum Beispiel was echt Anständiges, wo man bestimmte Stimmungen wegnehmen kann.
Kannst du dich mit lauter Barbies morgens in der U-Bahn umgeben?
Nee, nur Happy People.
Wenn es dir scheiße geht und du kannst einfach diese glücklichen Menschen nicht mehr sehen, kannst du schön in die U-Bahn steigen. Aber da braucht man natürlich so eine Brille nicht für, weil so viele glückliche Leute gibt es ja auch nicht in der U-Bahn.
Ach doch, naja, mittlerweile wird es Frühling.
Ach, das bringt es ja auch total.
Gestern gab es so eine Pin und hinter ihm ist irgendwie Wasser, dann blenden sie glücklicherweise weg. Aber man kann vielleicht sagen zu diesen Überlegungen, wie das mein Klo mein Urin-Gehalt von wie sonst was misst, bevor irgendjemand überlegt, dass den Leuten nach Hause zu stellen, würde sowas im Krankenhaus sein und da gibt es das heute nicht. Insofern, da müssen wir keine Angst haben. Also alles, was so kraftwerdliche Funktionen misst, kann man erstmal ein guter Frühdetektor, also mindestens 5 Jahre, bevor sowas in die Hand kommt.
Ja, ok, also bloß guck dir mal an, was man gerade heutzutage schon an Elektronik in der Apotheke kaufen kann.
Ja, aber das ist doch alles irgendwie die meisten Sachen so da echt neb.
Ich war neulich mal da und hab mir mal geguckt, was es da so gibt. Du kannst mittlerweile irgendwie ordentliche Blutdreckmessgeräte kaufen. Du kannst irgendwie Thermometer kaufen, die hältst du kurz ins Ohr und dann sagen die, wie warm es im Kopf ist. Ich hab irgendwie ein Digital-Test gemacht. Und solche Geschichten.
Hey, cooler Reifen.
Es gibt hier gerade ne Meldung im Chat, dass WWW-NATO-Punkt in Tod ist.
Das sollten wir uns doch gleich mal angucken.
Oha, ich will lange ab und halb richtig lernen.
Ich mein, das ist ein lehnendes NT-Server, das sollte uns nicht wirklich wundern.
Abgesehen davon glaube ich aber, dass solche Geschichten wie zum Beispiel Urinprobe analysieren, was immer erstmal so lustig klingt, aber das macht ja, wenn man ein bisschen weiter denkt, durchaus Sinn. Und zwar macht es unter anderem deswegen Sinn, weil es die Staatskasse weniger belastet. Wenn du zum Beispiel an ältere Menschen denkst, die so zum Beispiel irgendwie in Kontakt, also das klingt jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen blöder, aber die können so in einem Kontakt zu ihrem Hausarzt stehen oder zu dem betreuenden Arzt, ohne mal salopp gesagt, im Krankenhaus oder Altersheim, als sowas nur in öffentlichen Einrichtungen mit Personen und so weiter und so fort zu machen. Ich glaube schon, dass sowas kommen wird, vielleicht nicht im täglichen Bereich für alle, aber in bestimmten Fällen, glaube ich, kann das durchaus passieren.
Naja, da muss man jedoch Sachen sagen. Erstmal meine ich ja nicht, dass sowas in öffentlichen Institutionen eingesetzt wird, um zu testen, ob das dann zuhause funktioniert. Sondern wenn irgendeine gesundheitliche Maschine entwickelt werden soll, dann wird man sie erst im Krankenhaus einsetzen, einfach weil so Maschinen auch Lizenzen brauchen. Aber was ich als kritischen Punkt sehe bei sowas ist, einfach die Fehlerbehandlung ist immer so ein Wunderpunkt bei Software. Und jetzt nehmen wir mal an, die Maschine misst jetzt, dass der Blutdruck nicht in Ordnung ist und versucht dann den Arzt zu erreichen. Und gerade Kommunikation über Netzwerke hat immer das Problem, dass da manchmal Fehler auftreten, die manchmal... Und dann hat sich da ein Programmierer vertan und dann kommt es die beim Arzt an. Und dann stellt sich die eben die Frage, solche Kosten zu kalkulieren, ist im Grunde nicht möglich. Außerdem, so eine Geräte, wenn die entwickelt werden, das wird auch auf Staatskosten gemacht. Da wird übelst so pensioniert, gewöhnlich. Also ob das wirklich billiger wird, da muss man sich fragen. Außerdem der Elektro-Smog, der durch solche Geräte entsteht, das ist dann auch alles wieder... Also ich meine, ich finde das keine schöne Vision, dass irgendwie meine Oma in einem Hightech-Palast wohnt, so borgmäßig da alle Windeln verkabelt.
Also das muss das sein. Na ja, weiß ich nicht. Erstmal hast du recht, aber ob das eine schöne Vision ist, ist eine andere Frage. Es gab tatsächlich Leute, die die Vision, dass sie da ein Gerät auf dem Tisch stehen haben und das hat eine Nummer und jeder andere kann diese Nummer wählen und sie damit erreichen.
Welcher kritische Philosoph hat gleich der Meinung, dass die Einführung des Theaters doch die Jugend versauen würde?
Der hat doch recht gehört, ich meine.
Welcher Jugendliche hat denn das Theater?
Das meiner Meinung nach ist vielleicht nur anders.
Warte mal, was ist mit NATO, wo sind die?
Die sind mittlerweile wieder online, die werden so ein bisschen attackiert und jetzt gucken alle Leute natürlich nach, ob sie denn noch gehen und dann wird sie richtig in die Knie.
Aber ich stelle gerade fest, dass das NATO dir eh noch frei ist, falls du jemanden treffen kannst.
Die können doch gerade sehr populär sein, vielleicht kannst du sie ja an die Serben verscheuern, haben die Spaß. Ach, wir haben jetzt übrigens schon Ökosteuer, ne?
23 Minuten.
Ich meine, was für ein tolles Konzept. Ich meine, da wird irgendwie der Steinkohlebergbau damit subventioniert, dass irgendwie Steuer darauf erhoben wird. Die haben halt einen großen Topf und da geht was rein und was raus. Ich meine, wenn du anfängst, Industrien zu subventionieren oder irgendwie von Steuern auszunehmen, die halt massiv viel Energie verbrauchen und viel Umwelt verschmutzen, dann ist das schon ziemlich sinnlos.
Arbeitsplätze?
Naja, aber das nennt man dann Ökosteuer.
Jeden gottverdammten Bergmann, der da irgendwie rumsitzt, irgendwie die Kohle in der Hand drücken würde, wo das mit der irgendwie subventioniert wird, dann könnte der super viele Arbeitsplätze schaffen.
Meine Meinung dazu ist genau die, aber...
Das darfst du nicht sagen.
Das ist das Argument.
Das darf nicht rechtlicher Moderator sein.
Nee, das hat damit nichts zu tun.
Wir werden hier nicht sensiert. Du musst bestimmt noch mal nach Cottbus in den Tagebau irgendwann.
Nichts gegen Cottbus. Wir können übrigens mal eine schöne Sendung machen zum Thema Politik.
Genau.
Immunität in drei Stunden hier vereinbaren.
Das würden wir glaube ich nicht machen.
Drei anonyme Chaos-Mitglieder, die stürmend verzwehrt.
Ich stürze vor allem.
Das wäre eine gute Idee. Wir können uns schön mit Hörern fetzen und so.
Ja, gute Idee. Dann machen wir uns nichts weiter einführt.
Nächsten Monat?
Nee, irgendwann demnächst müssen wir 2000 noch mal, wenn wir uns noch genug fetzen. Wir wollten noch irgendwie auf CPUs an ungewöhnlichen Orten eingehen. Wir hatten jetzt gerade Roboclos. Mir ist neulich eine CPU begegnet in einem Ort, wo ich es echt nicht erwartet hätte. Und zwar in einem Instrumenten-Laden. Da habe ich so eine Klampe, ich glaube so eine Balalaika oder so. Zisiliertes Instrument mit irgendwie ein Tarsien. Super fein gearbeitet. So an, wie sollte ein unglaublichen Berg Geld kosten, 5-stellig. Und dann sagt er plötzlich hinten so, da hat er keinen Aufnehmer. Da fragte er, was das ist. Na ja, meinte er, da ist ein kleiner Rechner drinnen. Und der protokolliert halt Temperatur und Luftfeuchtigkeit, der dieses Instrument ausgesetzt ist. Und dann helft dir es dann irgendwie beim Nachstimmen und irgendwie für die Garantie und so weiter. Super. Also es fängt langsam wirklich an so mit den CPUs.
Also CPU-Ankörper hatten wir vorhin auch schon. Das ist natürlich CPU-Imkörper.
Und was ist denn mit Herzschrittmachern?
Herzschrittmacher sind zum Beispiel das kanonische Beispiel dafür. Und es gibt auch lustigste Geschichten. Also mittlerweile gibt es Defibrillatoren.
Also Defibrillatoren, das sind eigentlich die Teile in den Amiserien mit in der Arzt immer so zwei Elektrotöpfe, zwei Kochtöpfe auf die Brust. Dem Patienten, da ist dann ein kleiner Prozessor drauf, der stellt dann eben fest, ob das Herz gerade stehen geblieben ist. Das macht man bei Leuten, die schonmal einen Herzinfarkt hatten, wo man also annimmt, dass das wiederkommt. Und das ist leider momentan noch eine richtig teure Aktion. Das gibt es noch nicht lange, aber das wird eben momentan eingepflanzt. Und das Problem dabei ist natürlich, dass der Prozessor erkennen muss, ob das Herz jetzt kurz davor ist stehen zu bleiben oder ob der Patient irgendwie gerade eine Stresssituation hat. Und jetzt gibt es da so Anekdoten von Patienten, die dann eben auf dem Klo saßen und richtig doll drückten. Das klingt jetzt wie eine Urban Legend, das ist es aber nicht. Und wo dann das Gerät dachte, der kriegt da einen Herzinfarkt und dem dann halt so einen Stromschlag versetzt hat. Das fühlt sich für den Patienten an, als wenn ihm einer so richtig ins Kreuz tritt. Also so eine Probleme gibt es da im Moment noch. Aber es ist schwer zu testen, weil die Implantate dürfen natürlich erst eingebaut werden, nachdem da jahrelang an Tieren und sonst was getestet wurde.
Aber bei den Amis gibt es die Gesetzgebung da ein bisschen anders?
Natürlich, aber das Testen ist ja nicht so, dass die nicht funktionieren, sondern dass eben pro Patient anders ist, wie jetzt das Herz. Also ob man jetzt sagen kann, da ist irgendwie gerade ein Herzflimmern oder nicht. Und das muss eben eingestellt werden. Und dann nimmt man halt vorher EKGs auf und belastet den Patienten. Aber wenn dann halt mal eine schlimmere Last kommt, dann muss dann eben der Arzt schätzen. Und Herzgut mache das natürlich auch. Ganz klar ist ja das kanonische Beispiel, dass die Leute dann Angst haben, durch diese Metalldirektoren zu gehen. Aber eine Sache, von der ich jetzt wirklich nicht weiß, ob es eine Legende ist oder nicht, soll mal jemand mit so einem Defibrillator durch ein Diebstahlschutzsystem gelaufen sein, in einem Kaufhaus und daraufhin ist das Ding da eben zusammengebrochen. Und das sind eben so Wechselwirkungen, wo man dann eben dann doch anfängt nachzudenken, ob das gut ist, wenn wir alle überall irgendwelche CPUs haben.
Ja, was ich noch gesehen habe, was es gibt, sind Gehirnschrittmacher. Und zwar bei epileptischen Anfällen gibt es Sensoren, die feststellen, dass da so ein Anfall bevorsteht und eine gewisse Gehirnregion unter Strom setzt und zu verhindern, dass sich das ausbreitet. Ja, dann bei Leuten, wo das Innenohr zerstört ist, gibt es so Geschichten, dass man sich direkt einen Nerv ankoppelt auf verschiedenen Frequenzbereichen. Da hat man dann auch eine CPU, die das in die Frequenzbereiche aufteilt und dann die entsprechenden Nervenenden stimuliert. Genau. Und außerdem gab es da so einen verrückten britischen Wissenschaftler. Was war das? Die Tür ist dann automatisch aufgegangen, wenn wir dran vorbeigegangen waren. Er ist gemeint, das wäre die Zukunft.
Wie mache ich denn, wenn es freudig läuft, durch meine Vorausschreitungen gehen auf...
Ist das dieser Irre, der sich überall irgendwie...
Nee, nee, das ist noch ein anderer. Das ist der Larc. Der wie mit dem dritten Arm und so weiter.
Es gibt noch natürlich im Bereich, weil du gesagt hast, gerade Ohren gibt es für die Augen.
Da wird er irgendwie gerade...
Na ja, Sprachsynthesizer kennt man ja auch. Also Leute, die eben Krebs hatten. Luftwellenkrebs. Das sind natürlich auch Embedded-Prozessionen.
Gleich mehr ungewöhnliche Orte. Vielleicht der von euch auch. Ihr könnt gleich nochmal anrufen. Es gibt eine Telefonnummer, die lautet 03314 Potsdam 70 97 110. Jetzt gibt es aber erstmal ein Fritz-Kurzinfo. Und wenn euch noch CPUs Prozesse einfallen, dann ruft uns an und berichtet uns davon. Also Balalaika schon, aber nicht mit CPU. Ja Ab jetzt schon im Hintergrund zu hören und bis 1 Uhr dann übrigens Musik gemixt von Chemistry und Storm, ein weiteres DJ-Team aus der DJ-Kicks-Serie von Studio Kasim.
Luftalarm, NATO-Kampfflugzeuge sind zu neuen Angriffen gegen serbische Ziele gestartet. Nach einem Bericht des italienischen Fernsehens stiegen am Abend von den Stützpunkten Aviano und Piacenza zahlreiche Maschinen auf. Die NATO will die Bombardements gegen Jugoslawien ausweiten und auch über Ostern fortsetzen. Mobilmachung, die Untergrundarmee Uchika hat am Abend alle Kosovo-Albaner zwischen 18 und 50 Jahren zu den Waffen gerufen. In einer Fernseherklärung hieß es, man wolle den serbischen Einheiten in der Krisenprovinz mehr Widerstand leisten. Vermittlungsversuch, eine hochrangige russische Parlamentariergruppe ist von Moskau nach Belgrad abgereist. Die Delegation unter Leitung des Vizepräsidenten der Duma Baburin will den jugoslawischen Staatshef Milošević zu einer Vereinbarung bewegen. Hindernisse, die vollständige Umsetzung des vor einem Jahr geschlossenen Nordirland-Vertrages wird weiter vom Streit zwischen Protestanten und Katholiken blockiert. Beide Seiten können sich nicht einigen, wann die Untergrundorganisation IRA ihre Waffen abgeben muss. Der britische Premier Blair und sein irischer Kollege Erhörn hatten in Belfast drei Tage lang vergeblich versucht zu vermitteln. Fußball. Die deutsche Nationalmannschaft hat in Nürnberg das EM-Qualifikationsspiel gegen Finnland mit 2 zu 0 gewonnen. Der amtierende Europameister übernahm mit dem Sieg die Tabellenführung in der Gruppe 3.
Wette.
Heute Nacht gering bewirkt bei 6 bis 0 Grad am Tag nach Nebelauflösung meist sonnig Temperaturen 14 bis 18 Grad.
Verkehr.
Keine aktuellen Meldungen zur Zeit.
Ein Fritz kurz informiert Gerrit Kötterheimrich.
Fritz präsentiert Klopper, Rülps, Dux, Vans, Kavasa, Scania, Volvo, Saab, Dark, Blade, DiKea, No.
Genau.
The Cardigans The Cardigans Live in Berlin, Mittwoch, 7. April. Wegen der großen Nachfrage verlebt in die Columbia-Halle. Präsentiert von Fritz.
Genauso wie diese Sendung, die heißt Chaos Radio. Noch 26 Minuten lang der Computer-Plemon bei Fritz. Jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat mit dem Chaos Computer Club und mit Johnny. Es gibt tatsächlich ein paar Anrufer, die noch ungewöhnliche Orte für CPUs dazu addieren können. Eine andere Frage wäre zum Beispiel, auch noch jemanden besprechen könnte, an welchen Orten brauchen wir unbedingt noch CPUs? Ich denke zum Beispiel an Mülleimer, die automatisch trennen. Oder an Sexspielzeuge. An was?
Sexspielzeuge.
Sexspielzeuge, warum nicht?
Da ist irgendwie echt noch ein weites Feld. Ich meine, ich kenne den Markt da nicht so richtig.
Was guckst du mich an?
Ich schalte.
Ich kenne mich ja nicht, ich kenne es alles. Du kennst alles.
Wie ist da so die CPU-Dichtregung?
Ich glaube gar nicht, oder?
Ist das noch ziemlich mechanisch, oder gibt es mittlerweile Vibratoren mit feiner Regelung?
Nein.
Mit Widerstandserkennung?
Vielleicht sollten wir mal ins Porno-embedded CPU-Business gehen?
Nein, aber es gab da so einen Verrückten, der hat einen Mülleimer gebaut, wo der bei Müllermannwand hat, einen Mülleimer gebaut mit Barcode-Leser, der hat eben die Sachen da nachgekauft, die man weggeschmissen hat. Ist natürlich echt scheiße, wenn man da Werbegeschenke wegschminkt.
Rauszukriegen, welchen Joghurt von den vielen Westjoghurts man nur eigentlich essen kann und welche eklig sind. Wenn ich dran denke, okay, der hat jetzt alles nachgekauft, was ich damals weggehauen habe. Okay, Erman Haselnuss.
Aber gibt es das nicht in ganz simplen Sachen zum Beispiel? Warum habe ich keinen Wasserhahn, der einfach immer die richtige Temperatur liefert, die ich einmal eingestellt habe?
Was ich noch interessanter finde, da kannst du hier vom Glück reden, hast du mal einen amerikanischen Wasserhahn gesehen? Das sieht überhaupt überlebender. Den dreht man an und dann kommt erst mal kalt raus. Aber so richtig lange, und dann muss man einmal richtig rumdrehen und dann wird es dann warm. Das heißt, das ist unter der Dusche so richtig unangenehm, weil man muss halt erst mal so eine Minute echt kalt überleben, bevor es dann warm wird. Ich brauch da keinen Mikroprozessor. Ich kann mir zu Hause auch so ein bisschen nachpassen.
Kranuschen Stil anbieten. Genau.
GI.
Echte GI.
Wohnung, mit erst ganz lange Kaltwasser.
Was wird Schlammbecken irgendwie zum Durchroben?
Ich glaube, die einzige Wohnung, in der so Warmwasser und Kaltwasser in einem vernünftigen Verhältnis standen und auch der Wasserdruck genau richtig war, war die in der ich aufgewachsen bin, als ich klein war. Danach, alle meine eigenen Wohnungen hatten immer Probleme mit Wassertemperatur.
Weil der Trick ist, als du klein warst, hat das eine genügend lange Trainingsphase.
Das kann sein. Ich habe so noch nicht drüber nachgedacht. Ich glaube, das war die einzige Neubauwohnung, in der ich gewohnt habe. Wenn man da richtig Wasserdruck und auch heißes Wasser hatte.
In der Regel ist das Kaltwasser aus den warmen Wasserhähnen ein Problem, dadurch zu begründen, dass es an einem Ort der Wohnung an warmem Wasser ankommt, müssen erst mal 20 Meter Kaltwasser weglaufen.
Das ist überhaupt kein Problem. Das kann man heute bereinigen, indem man das Rohr hin und zurück legt und das Wasser ständig zirkulieren lässt.
Was natürlich Strom kostet.
Überhaupt kein Problem. Ja, das ist vernachlässigbar. Das kann man mit der Abwärme, der Heizung machen. Die Heizung verbraucht eher Strom.
Speziell bei uns wäre das mit der Heizung schwierig.
Bei uns hieß es eben, das wäre so teuer, diese Rückleitung da rein zu legen, weil das ist ja Altbau, da muss man alles aufreißen. Da haben wir doch gerade frisch verputzt und deswegen habe ich jetzt Kaltwasser in der Wohnung.
Das ist überhaupt nicht schlimm, das ist gesund. Kalt duschen ist gesund. Außer den Trend habe ich gerade gehört. Den Trend, echt?
Das könnte ich glaube ich gut heißen, wenn mein Bad beheizt wäre.
Das ist ein Problem. Ah super, ins kalte Bad kommen und erstmal schön kalt duschen. Ah, mann oder maus? Wer ist denn da? Hans, hast du noch Ideen für ungewöhnliche Orte?
Ja, hinter meinen Augen der Biochip.
Was willst du damit machen?
Ich meine, dieser Chip wiegt alle Intel-Chips auf, die die jemals produziert haben.
Hast du denn jetzt mal Spaß beiseite? Nehmen wir mal an, es gäbe...
Ein Chip, der zum Beispiel anzeigt, wenn die Badhaare eine bestimmte Länge haben, das dann blinkt vor den Augen und manövriert sich.
Dieser Chip heißt bei mir zu Hause Spiegel.
Also wenn es bei mir immer vor den Augen blinkt, wenn ich mir das anzeige, dann bin ich auch ein Spiegel.
Und wenn ich mir die Haare am Tag nicht geschnitten habe, dann zeigt das an, dass man ja mal kämmen muss.
Also ich meine, wir werden sicherlich noch Gehirnimplantate erleben. Das war vor einem halben Jahr ungefähr, dass sie dieses Basisproblem gelöst haben, wie man es zu Neuronen interface und ich denke mal, es wird nicht mehr als 20 Jahre dauern, bis sie signifikante Fortschritte machen.
Du meinst aber nicht Gehirnimplantate, sondern Kopfimplantate.
Das war doch gerade neulich in der CTF. Nee, Grundlagenforschung haben sie da mal dargestellt.
Naja, da passiert irgendwie gerade einiges. Also da denke ich, da werden wir noch einiges erwarten können. Ich denke, die Anreicherung des menschlichen Körpers mit CPUs, die wird sicherlich voranschreibt und spätestens, wenn sie das mit den Displays direkt in die Augen hinbekommen haben, werden wir alle kleine Stöcke irgendwo hinter den Augen.
Naja, aber ihr habt ja vorhin schon das Problem so angesprochen, dass es vielleicht nicht unbedingt die beste Lösung ist. Wenn da einer in Kaufhaus geht und gleich zusammenbricht, nur weil die elektronische Klauhilfe da funktioniert oder...
Na und denk mal an den Metalldetektor am Flughafen, wenn du das mal...
Also da kann man im Grunde genommen froh sein, dass man so eine Dinger noch nicht im Körper hat.
Ich mein, stell dir vor...
Wo wir wieder beim Defibrillator sind, der...
Stell dir vor, du läufst rum und plötzlich siehst du vor deinen Augen, flimmern, Windows CE verursachte eine allgemeine Schutzverletzung an ihrem Gehirn. Implantat, bitte starten sie sich neu. Ich mein, das ist schon ein echtes Problem, glaube ich. Aber jetzt mal, würdest du denn... Nehmen wir mal, es gäbe ein ganz simples Implantat, weiß ich nicht. Das setzt an dir, ist ganz klein, Eingriff und so. Und das dafür, dass du einfach mit Wehschlaf auskommst, zum Beispiel. Du brauchst drei Stunden Schlaf, innerhalb von 24 Stunden bist du ausgeruht, wie du sonst nach acht Stunden schlafst. Würdest du der Erste, der in der Schlange steht, oder würdest du auf jeden Fall abhängen von sowas nehmen?
Also ich würde das eine noch das andere. Zumindest würde ich mir das ganz gründlich überlegen. Mit solchen Sachen haben wir nicht Spaß. Ich meine, die Evolution hat den Körper so gegeben, wie er im Moment ist. Und ich weiß nicht, ob man da einfach so unbeschränkteren Tränen hat.
Also ich denke, man sollte auf jeden Fall bis zur Release zwei warten, bis man gerade verrückt ist aus dem Computer.
Und nur auf dem Source.
Und dann wartet man, bis man, ob es nur darum geht, nicht zu schlafen. Ich weiß nicht.
War jetzt ein Beispiel, einfach um was Simples zu erzählen?
Na Datenbüchse sind das erste, schätze ich.
Ja, austesten. Soll ich sagen, kann man den einfach austesten. Wenn es, sagen wir mal, nicht an die Existenz geht oder so. Ein ewiger Wahnsinn oder sowas.
Also mit anderen Worten wäre es garantiert nicht Betatester, aber würde es...
Nee, nicht Betatester, nicht Betatester, sondern... Wenn jeder Buckfix raus ist, dann würde ich...
Okay, ich dank dir erstmal.
Nein, Moment! Ich hab mal eine andere Frage. Diese Motorola-Ships, sind die endlich in jedem Board? Die sind ja gesorgt, im je Board zu betreiben. Muss man da irgendwie Apple-Board nehmen oder irgendwie?
Motorola wird irgendwie über 10.000 verschiedene Chiparten. Musst du ein bisschen spezifizieren inzwischen.
Also dann meine ich, ich hätte den, der im App verbaut wird.
Das sind die Power-PCs. Die PCs gibt es halt irgendwie tatsächlich nur eine große Mainboard-Sorte. Das sind halt tatsächlich die Apple-Mainboards. Und da musst du dir halt einen Mac kaufen, wenn du die haben willst. Es gibt noch ein paar Exot-Mainboards, auf denen die drauf sind. Aber in der Regel sind es halt die meisten. Ja, kannst du sicherlich irgendwie, wenn du in der Lage bist, irgendwie 6-Ebenen-Leiterplatten irgendwie mit 0, 1 mm Leiterbahnabstand selbst zu fertigen.
Es gibt doch Refin-Sports von Motorola. Ja, du musst halt bei Motorola rufen, sagen, dass du die Welt warst.
Aber ich glaube, du willst auch nicht wirklich ein eigenes Betriebssystem dafür schreiben.
Naja, das liest sich dann alles im Nachhinein entscheiden. Das gleiche mit dem Alpha-Ship, 121.64.
Wie, ob du da ein Mainboard für bauen kannst?
Ne, nicht bauen kann.
Ja, natürlich, du kannst auch ganze PCs da mit dir zusammen basteln. Kannst du bei Samsung oder bei...
Okay, das war's. Ich sag dreimal C und digital.
Warte mal, ich habe aus dem Chat gerade noch der Hinweis, RS1000 wird auch mit Porta PCs betrieben.
Moment, das war jetzt schon beinahe...
RS6000 von IBM ist eine Workstation-Familie, wird auch mit Porta PC betrieben.
Danke dir, tschüss, schönen Abend. Schönen Morgen muss man ja langsam sagen. Jetzt sind die Leitungen auf einmal, das ist immer so. Zehn Minuten Verschluss der Sendung, plötzlich 110 Leitungen.
Na die Leute kommen jetzt alle gerade aus der Schlange von der Tankstelle. Ich meine, kein Scheiß, auf dem Hinweg hierher sind wir bei der Tankstelle vorbei gekommen.
Stimmt, ein bisschen Cola wollten wir kaufen.
Irgendwie alle Leute, die mit tiefer gelegten Breitreifen-Golfs hier durch die Parkhacheln waren, waren an dieser Tankstelle vorzufinden.
Stimmt, ich hab mich gewundert, was los ist.
Na Öko-Steuer.
Ich hab überhaupt nicht dran gedacht.
Und das Lustige ist ja, die ganzen Tankstellen im Westen, also da wo ich wohne, ich bin es aufgefallen, die haben alle festgestellt, heute kommt die Panik-Kaffee, dann machen wir doch heute schon mal teurer. Das fand ich eine echte Frechheit, muss ich sagen.
Das finde ich ziemlich okay.
Ich finde, wenn Leute sich an eine Riesenschlange stellen, um 5 Mark zu sparen...
Nein natürlich, da haben sie es verdient. Aber hier noch ein guter Schub fällt mir gerade ein, wenn Leute glauben, sie möchten weniger schlafen oder sie haben zu wenig Zeit. Ihr habt alle genauso viel Zeit wie Marie Curie und Albert Einstein.
In diesem Sinne, wer ist jetzt am Telefon?
Also ich hab noch eine Idee, und zwar Parkinson-Krank. Die bekommen auch solche kleinen Elektroden eingepflanzt.
Ist das jetzt eine Idee von dir oder gibt es das?
Ein Freund von mir arbeitet da in so einer OP, wo die sowas machen.
Hast du ein bisschen mehr Info drüber? Hab ich noch nie von gehört.
Also man hat irgendwie festgestellt, dass irgendwelche Impulse da im Gehirn nicht richtig funktionieren. Und dann gleicht man die einfach aus. Und das hat bei 80% der Leute wohl eine ganz gute Wirkung.
Naja, ich meine gerade in der Medizin sind sie da echt heftig am machen. Also in Prothesen zum Beispiel werden mittlerweile auch schon Counter eingebaut, wie lange die Dinge jetzt schon gelaufen sind und so.
Naja überhaupt, es gibt ja Armprothesen, wo man dann tatsächlich fühlen kann, so ein bisschen mit dem Arm, ob der gerade irgendwas abgefahren ist.
Und bei der Parkinson-Kreide wird das tatsächlich schon angesetzt?
Ja wird schon gemacht.
Interessant. Ich danke dir. Ich finde, da wird es dann auch diese moralische, ethische und dann auch religiöse Fragen irgendwie, was darf man mit dem Körper machen und so weiter, irgendwie wird dann wirklich schwierig. Deswegen habe ich vorhin gefragt, ob derjenige sich halt irgendwas, würde irgendjemand von euch sich was implantieren lassen? Oder gibt es, sagt ihr alle, auf einen Fall?
Also nicht, wenn es uns ins Hirn geht.
Also wenn der Arzt vor dir steht und sagt, sie haben noch zehn Minuten zu leben oder sie lassen uns diese Operation machen, dann sagt jeder ja. Das ist das Problem. Auch viele Leute sagen, wenn sie dann alt werden und den anderen Leuten in ihrer Familie in den Geist gehen und denen nur noch Geld kosten, dann würden sie Selbstmord begehen. Das macht dann doch keiner. Also das ist immer einfach im Vorhinein zu sagen, wenn der Mann im Kittel vor einem steht und sagt, wenn sie ihre Familie noch mal sehen wollen, dann müssen sie diese experimentelle Verfahren machen lassen und dann machen sie das.
Also vor allen Dingen, ist der nicht der Herzschrottmacher? Ich weiß nicht, wie lange gibt es Herzschrottmacher?
Über 20 Jahre.
Ist der nicht eigentlich die erste Form von so einem Eingriff gewesen? Insofern finde ich die Diskussion... Also es gibt ja dann diese Diskussion von Leuten, die sagen, auf keinen Fall und da kommt nichts unter die Haut und so. An sich ist das ja schon sowas. Naja, wollte ich noch mal sagen.
Ja, ich habe mich schon einmal in der Leitung gehört zu und bei der mich auch.
Gut. Jetzt werden wir dich auch.
Genau. Michael mein Name.
Hallo, Michael.
Ich habe mir gerade gedacht, da gibt es so schöne Arme dazu. Diesen Film, Late Runner, von heute Scott.
Und kennt ihr den?
Natürlich. Ja, ich meine, das ist so die Erinnerung unserer Vergangenheit, auch Implantate sind. Und ich habe jetzt gerade ein bisschen dran gedacht, als ihr so geplaudert habt. Ich ruf an mit anderem. Ich kriege den ORB über Satellit, über Astra. Und habe so alle 20 Minuten, halbe Stunde eine Runden. Und das kommt auf allen Kanälen von ORB. Habt ihr dann eine Ahnung dazu, woran das liegt?
Überhaupt keine NATO-Übertragung.
Vielleicht können die Kollegen der Qualitätskontrolle Chaos Center mal einen Blick auf die Oszillusgruppe werfen.
Ja, und euer Moderator, der Johnny, weiß da auch nichts dazu.
Keinen Schimmer von.
Also wir sprechen hier in dem Mikrofon und wir hoffen, dass es auf der anderen Seite ankommt.
Wir wissen ja nicht mal, ob das, was wir hier sagen, tatsächlich auch bei euch ankommt. Zum Thema Blade Runner. Nee, hab ich leider überhaupt keine Ahnung von. Und ich würde dir da empfehlen, morgen in so normalen Bürozeiten mal anzurufen. Und da kann man sich jetzt so jemanden durchstellen, der irgendwie da für zuständig ist.
Selbe Nummer?
Nee, nicht selbe Nummer. Da würde ich... ORB Zentrale.
Auskunft.
165.
Ja, euch prüfen zwei Gelegenheit. Krieg ich ja auch bei dir Auskunft.
Da hab ich ja leider überhaupt keine Ahnung von.
Man muss jetzt hier immer einmal im Monat kommen, um irgendwie kurz vor zehn Reihen sitzen, uns hierhin sprechen, in dem Mikrofon hoffen, dass es funktioniert und gehen dann wieder nach Hause. Also was hier so hinter den Kulissen passiert, davon sehen wir eigentlich relativ wenig.
Man muss wissen, dass ich das ja jetzt schon ein paar Jährchen mache, und trotzdem keine Ahnung, was in deinen Kulissen passiert.
Tja, also für mich ist das alles nur...
Was ich gerade selber reinigt.
Ich meinte gerade die andere Glastür.
Nee, unser Klo ist definitiv nicht selbst reinigend.
Also guck mal, Felix, da sind echt so viele Monitore.
Gibt es eine Schätzung, wie viele Mikroprozessoren in dieser Sendung beteiligt sind?
Also meiner Schätzung ist irgendwie dreistellig.
Würde ich auch schätzen. Mindestens. Also kommt drauf an, wo man den, wo man die ganze...
Wenn du dir alleine irgendwie dieses ganze Sound-Processing-Equipment hier anguckst.
Naja, wenn du irgendwie sagst, Astra-Satellit.
Ja, allein was nur in diesem Raum hier steht, ist glaube ich schon dreistellig. Ich bin ziemlich fest von überzeugt. Okay, dann das selbst reinige Klo dazu. Ein Anrufer haben wir noch. Wer ist da? Also wir haben noch mehrere, aber Zeit nicht mehr für viele.
Super, hallo Johnny. Morgen CTC, ja. Nee, ich hab noch eine super Idee. Die ist zwar nicht ganz so toll für die Raucher, wahrscheinlich im Osten, aber in den Zigaretten, die versteuert sind, da müssten auch so embedded Systeme drin sein. Und in den Feuerzeugen ebenfalls. Und dann lassen die sich natürlich nur anstecken, wenn da auch die Steuer bezahlt ist. Also das funktioniert ja heute sehr schon. Man sieht ja öfter, die gehen überhaupt nicht an, die Dinger.
Wie, aber die Tatsache, dass sie bei dir nicht angehen, sagt, dass du unverstörende Zigaretten kaufst.
Ja, ich bin eigentlich nicht ein Fahrrad.
Aber das war eine schöne Schlussidee.
Ja, es gibt aber noch ein paar Boards, wo PowerPC drauf ist. Naja, für Amiga zum Beispiel.
Darauf hab ich eigentlich den ganzen Abend erwartet.
Wie haben Sie jeden Abend am Ende mindestens einer an und sagt, heut doch nicht rum, man.
Ich find das ja cool. Ich hab nach Linux PPC und hab nach Programmen gesucht. Und wenn man nach plus PowerPC plus Binary sucht, kriegt man 20:000 Amiga. Ich war echt beeindruckt, dass es noch so viele Leute gibt.
Ja, naja, das sind die Schämer dahinter. Ich kann ja mit der Kiste alles noch machen, was ich machen will.
Nee, um Gottes Willen, bleib bei PowerPC. Jeder Schlag gegen Intel ist einen Schritt nach vorne.
Ja, ich hab hier noch einen komischen Prozessor, einen 80C31, den ich mal quasi bei Erdarbeiten gefunden habe. Nee, ich hab mal so eine Erdarbeitsfirma und da hab ich es richtig so archäologisch, das kam aus der EMC, ja fast. Wir haben so Erde gesiebt und da kam so ein Entvieh und in dem Entvieh war so eine Art Karte, die so groß ist wie eine Zigaretten-Schachtel und dick ein Zentimeter, das Ding hab ich hochgeschraubt. Das ist richtig so ein massiver Spritzkursgehäuse, da kannst du ein Lager mit in die Wand hauen. Und ja, da ist so ein Intel-Prozessor drauf und ein Akku und diverse andere Dinge und das ist so, ja, Auslandskontakte, also ich weiß nicht, ob man das in seine Waschmaschine steckt oder an die S-Bahn und die fährt dann, keine Ahnung. Aber habt auch keine Ahnung, was das ist, was?
Klingt interessant.
Also das ist ein Intel-Prozessor von Philips hergestellt, aber ich weiß nicht, ob es eine ausländische Lösung ist mit einer Atombombe.
Du hast doch eine Atombombe mit Intel-Technologie ausbilden wollen.
You bet, dass sie das tun.
Immerhin simulieren sie Atombomben mit Intel-Technologie.
Dann kann man irgendwie noch einen Föhn draus basteln.
Ja schick dir doch mal den Club nach Berlin. Okay, die Adresse findest du im Web. Da gibt es einen Postfach. Pack einfach einen Umschlag und schick's uns.
Oh ja, nicht dass es dann als Bombe durchgeht oder so.
Nein, unser Post wird sorgfältig kontrolliert, also da brauchst du dir keine Sorgen machen. So, wir müssen nochmal irgendwie ein bisschen Propaganda machen.
Ja, mach.
Genau. Wie schon öfter erwähnt, wir haben im Sommer ein schönes Camp. August in der Nähe von Berlin.
Die Sonne wird scheinen.
Genau, die Sonne wird scheinen. Wir haben da eine feste Zusage.
Und wir haben Internet.
Wir haben viel Internet.
Genau, es wird irgendwie eine große Wiese geben, bringt alle eure Zelte mit, eure Rechner mit. Die näheren Daten findet ihr im Web unter www.ccc.de nicht zu übersehen.
Was hast du übrigens für Internet? Was wird da stehen?
Das werden deutlich mehr als Megabit sein, ja.
Deutlich zweistellig Megabit über Satellit, oder?
Das ist noch nicht geklärt. Also Satellit kriegt man nicht hin. Aber Faser oder Richtfunk, was anderes, kommt eigentlich nicht in Frage.
Also wir werden da einfach mal Internet haben. Geht davon aus, es wird genug sein für alle.
Das heißt jeder, der seine Teilnehmergebühr bezahlt hat, kommt dahin, kann sein Zelt aufschlagen, kriegt eine IP-Adresse mit einer Wäscheklammer.
Genau.
Und Internet in seinen Zelt gelegt.
Und Internet in seinen Zelt gelegt, wenn er vielleicht noch ein Hub mitbringt oder so.
Und Strom und einen dicken FTP-Server.
Und wir werden eine Cola-Wall haben.
Genau, wir werden echt eine Menge Spaß haben. Es gibt auch ein Säse, das man planchen kann. Und irgendwie der garantierte Sonnenschein sich dann auch gut abwaschen lässt, wenn es zu schwitzig war. Ja, also...
Das wird bestimmt extrem nett, spannend und lustig. Im Moment gibt es auch Gespräche darüber, ob man von da nicht auch Radio macht.
Genau.
Damit alle informiert sind. So was kann man ja inzwischen auch live auf den Netz übertragen. Es gibt ganz viele Ideen zu dieser Sache. Und es wird sich ja noch viel, viel größer. Und wir werden natürlich in den Sendungen und natürlich auf den Seiten von CCC, die natürlich unter www.ccc.de übrigens eine der tollsten Adressen, die...
Ansonsten wollen wir noch mal ein bisschen dafür werben. Der CCC beteiligt sich ja an dem Distributed-Net-Effort, um RC5 zu knacken. Und wir haben da auch unser eigenes Team.
Sind immer noch nicht fertig?
Nein, wir sind... 6, 4% Keyspace?
Ich weiß es nicht, aber es dauert noch projektiv mehrere hundert Jahre.
Dauert noch ein bisschen. Also wenn ihr bei uns mitrechnen wollt...
Nur Slore kommt uns zu Hilfe.
Wir sind irgendwie eines der am schnellsten wachsenden Teams. Und jeder Key zählt.
Lasst eure Palm-Palettes mitrechnen und eure Armbanduhrn. Und wenn jemand seinen Pager umbaut...
Hat jemand einen Client dafür geschrieben für ein Palm-Palette? Das war's mit dem Chaosradio. Die Ausgabe März.
Ich weiß nicht. Ich glaube noch nicht. Vielleicht hast du Tim ja schnell genug, uns in den Chat einzugeben, dann kann ich es noch ansagen.
Ansonsten machen wir halt...
Ah, Schulen und Medien ist das nächste Thema, wurde mir gerade mitgeteilt.
Schulen und Medien?
Genau. Erst Schulen, dann Medien.
Ich meine, die Bundesregierung hat ja immerhin versprochen, wie jeder Schule, bist du mehr aus einem Internetanschluss zu. Die Förderung der Medienkompetenz halte ich schon für ein erstrebenswertes Ziel. Insofern ist es ein gutes Thema.
Die Förderung der Medienkompetenz, super.
Ist ein Internetanschluss näher spezifiziert? Ein T-Online-Deil ab, ja.
Ich glaube, dass du in meine DPA meldest und da kannst du keine näheren Spezifikationen erwarten.
In diesem Sinne, mehr Spezifikationen gleich in den nächsten Stunden im Night Flight, nämlich mit Martin Petersdorf. Und in etwa vier Wochen, nämlich am letzten Mittwoch des Monats April, dann wieder mit dem Chaos Radio. Tschüss, viel Spaß am Gerät.